You threw me off the groove.
I was like, you're not supposed to talk back.
I'm here too.
Oh, guys.
Okay, so you guys might see like this little, sorry, I
looped the intro because like men and I were sharing
secrets.
Yeah, you're not invited.
They're really good.
Yeah, if only you could have heard what we said.
Oh, you'll never know.
You're gonna miss the FOMO.
Wait, no one did they want the FOMO?
Yeah.
You have FOMO.
Oh, you have FOMO.
What could we have said?
Oh my god, within like five minutes.
I'm gonna tell them right now.
All right, say it.
Because it's about you, so it's your secret.
What?
You ain't no, you told me stuff to do.
But the later half was your secret.
Oh, yeah.
First half was Doki's secret.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was my secret.
Yeah, so there's two secrets that you don't know.
Two whole secrets.
Oh, my God.
Two whole secrets that you were not there for.
How long are we going to drag?
We gotta give them all the FOMO.
Yes.
Now that we're in these, we don't have to deal with FOMO
anymore.
So we give you FOMO instead.
We give you FOMO.
We can do whatever we want.
Yeah.
Okay, so if you guys don't see the bottom right text on my
end, I don't know if you're showing it, Mint, but it says,
warning this version may cause the game to crash so it's not
our pc things it might be a kuso game yeah it might be it
might be because this is your decision yeah yeah i suggested
the game okay so um so this game i told mint that she has to
start a new game herself as well so like There's an intro to
the game.
So don't click multiplayer, right?
Yeah, don't click, just do new game.
And then you do normal.
And then you'll be met with like an intro.
Anyway, so those who don't know what hospital 666 is, it's
basically like that, was it platform 8?
The one with the subway?
So it's basically platform 8.
Or exit 8.
Sorry, exit 8.
It's basically exit 8.
But what if we added multiplayer in there?
How do you even do that?
I don't even know.
to find out now i wonder if it's like 666 floors i want
there's there's 66 anomaly how long is this we're gonna be
playing up until dokey's new model yeah yeah yeah new skin
suit yeah yeah this is 24 hours by the way you know surprise
you know like the the spookies like jump scare mansion
We're gonna make it to floor a thousand guys Is that
actually how long that game is?
No way.
Oh, yeah.
The spooky.
I never played the jump scare one No, no.
Oh, yeah, I think it is I think it's like I think it's I
played it before it's up to like a thousand floors And
because like every and then because every hundred you get
it's like a new like a new theme to the to the like rooms
and stuff So it gets spookier and spookier at one point one
of them was like uh one of the at one point you go go to a
floor that's just a fucking maze um thousand floors plus
bonus dlc floors yeah yeah more no it's oh wait yeah they
made more floors yeah there's dlc floors too and there's
like and then like and then you get taken to like a hospital
too it's like spookies and hospitals oh yeah and then i also
uh while we were like waiting for the stream um i linked
mint a really good i linked mint a vtuber background i was
like oh my god it's perfect it's so it's the best it's
actually i should have used it today honestly you should
have no that's what they want that's what the whisp one man
that background yeah yeah okay i'm gonna it's this one guys
we a link it's on my chat too and you being like you can
recreate that dr horrell bro everybody loves it helping that
random girl you see at the laundromat roleplay it's like
it's like the one of the top five cliches out there top five
dreams it's true and you could be that girl Yeah Oh my god
There's this There's this ghost made And that my laundromat
My laundromat's haunted Whoa Sookie
Because it was like Who wants this?
I was like what do you mean Who wants this?
No no no I said what led to them creating Like what was the
man?
Like who said man I really need like a laundromat?
She saw him girl at the laundromat he's like well that could
be if only vtubers had this too not enough anime start with
a guy meeting a girl at the laundromat he's like no he's
like you know like we the west version of weaboos like those
like the westaboos yeah the westaboos it's i bet you the
person who created is a westabo because they saw too many
like american tv shows where it starts off the laundromat
he's a west boo he wishes japan has more of this i'm gonna
throw chat in the laundry machine i'm gonna throw you guys
in the perfect rp i would make it so that the chat is like
there the laundromat's like overlaid on top of chat and then
yeah spinning spinning oh that's too much work for me i
won't be doing it yeah yeah check mint channels out if you
want to live your laundromat fantasies.
Wow.
See, that's why I linked you the background.
I knew you did.
You knew it was made for me.
I knew it was made for you.
This background's made for you.
All right, guys.
How's our volume, by the way, after all that?
Do I sound?
I'm going to start a new game.
Yeah, we're going to start a new game, too.
You guys got to see the intro.
Do I just do any difficulty?
Yeah, any difficulty, and then we'll hook.
Or do normal.
Actually.
Yeah.
okay i'm starting the game i'm go some go some balls wait is
this this is not game footage this is a real yeah this is
the dev
go some balls oh my god and now we're in the game
that was it yeah that was it that's what i wanted you to see
i was like what the fuck is now you're in the game too all
these instructions they have like the entire world wait is
he a vtuber yeah yeah he's apparently like um how guys by
the way guys this developer is single
so ladies and guys too sync on or off i can't i don't know
she asked me if she should play on dx11 or go and she was
like what what's the difference i was like i don't know
turning it on helped me not lag so okay that's good i'm
returning to the menu all right also sound guy turned up
mint up a bit more is it better now blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah all right let me i'll invite you let me go to
multiplayer Because I don't... Did you start it off on easy?
No, I did normal.
Okay.
I couldn't tell it.
Because you were like, oops.
And I was like, oh no, what do you mean?
Oops.
Or...
All right.
How do I invite you?
All right, give me a sec.
The friend's list is, like, empty for me.
Oh, okay.
So...
This is fine.
That should be fine, right?
All right.
I can invite you to watch this game.
wait can you go to multiplayer and see if you find me in the
game no you're not there I'm not there okay let me have no
friends I have no oh okay uh no I meant like uh you know how
you go to multiplayer do I show up on multiplayer no I don't
okay this is awkward what if I press host well if you're
hosting then I can let me I can join you try me try me okay
give me a sound all right return to menu
exist on my friends list wait can you invite me you guys
guys we're not professional like we're not indie you have to
have zero expectations on us when we're please understand
please understand it is just us right now we're not We
should not be put up to standards when it comes to corporate
VTubers.
We're just one person.
I say when I have a team behind me.
Well, I don't.
So I can actually actually be myself and I.
Yeah.
I invite friends.
Okay, hold on.
We're not even.
Okay, here you go.
I can invite to watch.
What?
I can watch you.
I was sorry.
I boosted her volume again.
sound guy how do i join you all right oh oh guys we're give
us a sec guys we totally instead of you know we made up 15
minutes before the stream started and instead of preparing
the stream we were sharing secrets okay we were sharing
secrets we had our priorities here it was like juicy good
yeah yeah if you knew the secret you would have been like
good choice You know?
Okay, I'm going to do friends.
I'm going to change my profile settings and see if you can
invite me now.
You see me on, I think you see me on YouTube studios instead
of hospital.
Can you?
Oh, wait.
I'm going to return to the menu.
Yeah.
I'm going to multiplayer.
I'm going to, I'll host.
I'm going to host a game.
I don't think if you host it, you'll show up.
right and then uh no it should be because like what's the
point of hosting it if you don't like what's the point of
hosting it how did the other people no there's no way other
vtubers were able to set this up we can't be asked we can't
be stupider than other vtubers like yes we can no we can
Have like almost equivalent IQ.
Wait, how do you add, or how do you invite someone on Steam?
I never remember.
Wait, what do you, wait, what?
That's what I was telling you to do.
Control.
Oh, I do that.
Shift tab.
What do you mean?
Nothing showed up.
Okay, go.
Just kidding, just kidding.
Okay.
Have you never done shift tab before?
What do you mean you've never?
Oh, okay.
Now, how do I add you?
All right, you see where Doki Bird is, and then you go to
invite.
Oh, I can invite you to watch.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying you can invite me to watch.
But it's not even watch the game.
It's watch V.
Richards.
I mean, don't you want to watch my face go up the whole
time?
The whole time, definitely.
We both have like a solo session of Hospital 666, and we're
just watching.
We sync up our Hospital 666 gameplay together.
And obviously.
Or like see who gets to the most floors.
We can make it a competition.
I'm going to restart my game.
I'm going to restart.
Maybe it's not us.
Maybe, guys, maybe it's not us.
We need to play in DX mode.
Oh, was it...
Did we actually have to play in DX mode?
I don't know.
Okay, you're just making shit up.
I got an achievement for leaving the game.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, we can do this, guys.
We can have chat.
No, it's good chat.
You guys get more content.
We could have ended earlier if we didn't have this.
I'm ending the stream right now.
Okay, I'm hosting again.
I'm hosting.
Wait, are you on DX11?
I'm on DX11, yeah.
Okay, I'm on the normal one, so I don't know if that affects
anything.
Oh.
Okay, can you see mine?
I see you!
Oh my gosh, it was DX11 all the time!
I'm joining.
Are you joining?
Hopefully it doesn't crash because it said that this
version...
I'm in the floor.
You're on the floor?
I don't see you?
No, I'm in the floor.
Wait, you're in the floor?
Where are you?
I hear noises It's me walking on top of you I think I hear
you walking Wait go towards the man with the hat Can I see
you?
Go towards the man with the hat Okay, hey, do you see me?
Do you see me?
Okay, I'm gonna leave you I'm gonna have- Go to the next
floor Yeah, go to the next floor Wait, wait, wait, we need
to remember I said layout!
This is what it looks like This is what they- Well, figure
it out!
This is okay!
This is a default!
just figure it out then figure it out okay okay all right
I'm gonna I'll leave you goodbye goodbye I see the doors go
where are you where did you go I'm still stuck in the floor
are you on the next I'm on the next floor I'm going up
another floor and see if I'm gonna go I'm gonna go back up
another floor are you still on the first floor i can't even
exit to the menu like pressing escape does nothing i'm still
on the second floor okay i'm leaving the game okay okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna start a new game okay okay i'll join you
i'll join you maybe that'll work Okay, okay.
I'm not doing the DX.
I'm joining normal.
All right.
I'm hosting.
Okay.
All right.
Sound guy.
I turned down mint a little bit.
Is it better now?
Better.
We're still adjusting sound while figuring out how to play
this game.
It's okay.
We're in these guys.
Okay.
Can you see me in the game?
No.
I don't see.
see you in the game no i do not okay well how did you see me
maybe it was the dx mode i'm telling okay i'll go i'll go on
dx mode we'll swap we'll just try hosting again and maybe
okay no i'll do dx mode this is so great you guys guys guys
we are professionals here all because we didn't even test it
because she was like you have to see the new game intro
that's not true we didn't test it because I showed her the
laundromat.
Get it right.
Sorry, my bad.
You're right.
There's a sequence of events that led to this.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you in the game yet?
I'm in the game, yeah.
Okay, because I don't see you.
Maybe it's because you're...
Are you like...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'm hosting.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I also have another idea.
I think it's because your Steam is on...
You don't show what game you're playing.
On Steam so because like I made mine friends only.
So like you should make yours friends only and then after
the stream we private it How do you do that?
You mean did you you set you have that's okay.
You good You know What did you learn in the last two three
years?
Did everything for me Why did you learn in the last three
Like what did you mean?
Okay, okay.
Go to Steam, click your name, click your name, go to privacy
settings.
Hold on, where is, hold on, click on.
Wait, under my profile.
Okay, you go to, yeah, go to, go to admit and then do it.
Go to edit profile.
Okay.
Yeah, and then friends only.
Oh my god, Miss Playing Hospital 666.
Oh my god, that actually fixed it.
Oh my god, I can see you now.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Come on, come on, come on.
Join the game.
Oh, there you are.
There I am.
Oh my god, it was the same thing all over again.
I can't believe you learned this as an indie.
I'm just getting my feet off the ground.
I've been around for two months.
Come on.
Give me a break.
You!
You can't say it!
You existed five years ago.
You can't say that.
When I existed, you existed.
When we were both Indies.
Okay, you know what, Doki, you need to shave, okay, come on.
Come on, get out of my way.
I'm ready to get out of this hospital.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Can we open the door?
How do you open the door?
I don't think we can.
I don't think we're allowed to.
Okay, we got, oh, wait, that's us.
That's us.
That's our triplet.
We're visiting our triplet at the hospital.
Solid, liquid, solid.
all right we gotta memorize this layout we gotta figure out
what the anomalies are later okay wait i heard that there's
like a thing i can do in multiplayer can i do it oh i can't
oh yeah i'm in the hospital man and i'm in the hospital
that's where you want to get beat up in the hospital don't
make me put some buddies you know i'm in here i'm here too
We're just spamming the button.
We're gonna punch you in the ball.
Now I put you first.
Oh yeah!
Are you gonna make it to the elevator?
The first one there is right now!
Yeah, push me back to the elevator.
I wanna make it before you!
I know!
Whoa!
Give me!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, I can't!
You can't punch people in the elevator!
Yes, you can!
I'm punching you right now.
I like how we are not checking the anomalies.
We're back to floor zero.
Wait, what do you mean we're back to floor zero?
Look at the elevator.
What do you mean what happened?
What do you mean?
We're advancing.
We played the game.
Damn it, I can't leave you.
I hadn't been to the floor.
All right.
I don't think there's any anomalies.
families.
Wait, are you getting coffee?
Yeah, not for you.
Why get coffee when we can get gamer subs?
I saw it.
Anyway, guys, did you guys know that we both have gamer
subs?
We both have goals.
Anyway, feel free to use a Doki Bird for 10% off and only
Doki Bird.
Or Boomer, which is the cooler, more trendy, more code to
use.
No, no, no.
Or you Or the link in the description.
There's no link in your description.
Yes, there is.
I'm getting to the elevator, bro.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
What?
Oh, we were...
Wait, you are!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I think there's a nominee here.
You think so?
Yeah, I think so.
What is it?
I don't think there was too...
Psych.
You can't even press the button.
No!
You can't even go.
I can't ditch you.
What's the point?
We have to find the anomaly.
Come on.
I don't know.
Everything looks the same.
Wait, isn't he on the other side?
No, he was always here.
No, because like, this is where we start off.
Because this is where you got coffee, remember?
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, and then you're like, go over here and you're like,
oh, there he is.
There's all the medicine.
There's this beautiful vista.
All right, let me read the rules.
You find Anomaly, press the elevator and press the button
for...
30 minutes into the stream.
We played this game for five minutes.
Wait.
20 minutes of this game with text support.
If you don't find the Anomaly, press the button from the
another elevator.
Oh, from the elevator over on this side.
So, if we don't find the Anomaly, we just gotta...
Oh, we come back here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can use the top button to review the previous floor.
Orange light outside means you're starting from this
elevator.
Oh, okay, so it tells you which elevator you start from.
No, if you don't find an anomaly, press the button from
another.
Oh, so if we find an anomaly, we come here.
If we don't find an anomaly, we go over there.
It's wherever elevator you start with.
Yeah.
Because both elevators have the same instruction.
So if we find an anomaly, we go up a floor.
I don't think there's, like, or like, yeah, I don't think
there is.
If we find one, we go here.
If we don't find one, we go down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, we press the...
Yeah, yeah.
No, it's an E because there's a restart.
There's a...
Oh, no.
That's if you want to go back to the previous floor.
Oh!
We're...
Guys, see, we can reign.
We...
Okay, do you think there's an anomaly?
No, I think so.
I think we're good.
All right, so...
Okay, hold on.
There's five...
Six doors.
Two, four, six.
Okay, one, two, three, four.
four, five, six.
That's what I said.
I don't know.
I'm worried you couldn't count, you know, because we're
YouTubers.
They care about our health.
Yeah, there's, like, lots of meds here.
Guys, remember to take your meds.
That's all of Doki's meds right there.
Yeah, and that...
Yeah, yeah, mids meds is in this room.
It's an entire room dedicated to it.
Okay, okay.
This one is so that she can count.
This one's so she can read.
This one is this one so that my imaginary Oh no, I need to
take my meds I've lost control of my heart This one is so my
imaginary friend will finally disappear But I didn't take it
That's why it's all here Why can't I punch you?
Alright, let's just go up Because I didn't take my med
Alright, we go, we go up I think we're Wait, what's that?
Alright, we'll see It's gonna go to two.
It's gonna go to two?
Yeah.
It's not moving.
Oh, it's back to zero.
I knew we fucked it up.
There's no...
What did we mess up?
Okay, wait.
So this is zero, so we can figure out what...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so...
Water.
Okay, exit side.
The meds are still here.
Water.
All right, there's a two trash cans.
Wait, did you count in the six doors?
Did you count?
Yes, I counted in the six doors.
I just wanted to be sure Okay, it's cafe cappuccino, cafe
con con what's it called?
Panah All right, I think we go up the floor.
I think I think this is what I think this is what pastry
zero looks like Maybe the side.
Yeah, maybe the side.
one we can pay attention we are vtubers there's two of us
like this is a amount of like five people this is a one to
four player game okay it's not our fault we're missing two
players to help us was this always here?
yeah this was always here okay I've seen this before okay
and there was always like two Okay, all right.
Okay, then let's stay on this elevator.
Let's stay over here and press a button if you don't trust
me.
I mean, the guy is...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God, there's an anomaly!
What's the anomaly?
This guy is running!
What?
Oh, my God!
Are you sure?
Wait, what do you mean by sure?
Do you not see it?
No, he's standing still.
Wait, actually?
Yeah.
Are you sure?
Are you gaslighting?
I have photographic proof.
I'm glad I'm streaming.
A photo means that it's a photo.
It's a snapshot.
A photo isn't animated.
That proves my point.
No, Chad.
I took my...
You guys, come on.
Believe me.
Come on.
Look at him.
He's running.
Wait, Mitch, Chad, it's not running, right?
Mince chat.
It's not running, right?
It's not.
I don't see it.
I'm pretty sure on our... I'm looking at stream right now.
It's not running.
Yes, yes!
Use your eyes!
You forgot to take the meds to use your eyes.
I can only see it five frames per second.
So...
Wait, so then that means we go to back to this one, right?
Yeah, we go back and we like go up.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, so like, you know how like...
like some camera like some video cameras can only see like
certain frames and then uh so like you can actually have
like a video of like a bird whose wings are just like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah those are my eyes right i think you need
to get help for that oh we're at tattoo we did it that was
me we didn't we did not we did it together this is a team
game it's a collab what you accomplish is
Oh my god, and now he's green.
He's not running at all.
All right.
I am looking at the calendar.
Medical center first.
Everything looks the same.
Yeah.
You know what?
I think you know who...
Wait!
There's three clocks!
Oh, there's... Wait, wasn't there always three clocks?
I only saw one before.
Maybe that was the anomaly.
Wait.
Maybe...
Oh, I think it is three clocks.
It's the anomaly.
Yeah.
So we go up from here.
doing so good teamwork we we're doing so good guys i think
you know what you know what who can be our third and fourth
player who chat yeah how true chat is like oh let's see one
o'clock one clock one clock oh my god i think we're really
good at this game this game is too easy yeah this game is
weird it's not like we fucked up like three times before you
figured it out the royal we yeah sure i don't think there's
any anomalies this time it doesn't look like it yeah well
you said that last time and there were three o'clock look i
didn't look behind me okay how many doors are there how many
doors one two three four five six see i can count too she
took her meds everybody yeah i took my meds you see
Come on, I can't go up a floor without you, man.
What are you doing?
Okay, don't go back to zero.
Wait, does it go back to zero?
Yeah, it goes back to zero.
We lose.
I don't even know how many floors it's supposed to be.
Four!
We're doing it!
All right, everything looks fine.
Okay, there's two fire...
Wait, wait, wait, the fire hydrants.
There's always been two.
Yeah, but then look at the labels.
Weren't they like together?
Like the same label?
Oh, I don't know.
But also, wait, we started on the other side.
Is that normal?
No, we went here.
We came to this elevator because there was no anomaly.
So we started on that side.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You're right, you're right.
Check the meds.
Mm-hmm.
Like I said, fire hydrants and you agreed with me.
What's oh fire
I told you chat oh There's there's there's there's there's
there's water it's leaking oh my god Wait, does someone here
wait, okay, that is water?
Why is there blood here?
Why is there blood on here?
Yeah, yeah, and it's old blood too because it's dark red
Ooh, somebody like stubbed their toe or something.
I think that it's a pretty extreme stubbed I think So we go
in this one, right?
No, we go on the other one.
There's Anomaly.
Okay, let's read the rules again.
I don't remember how we did this.
Okay.
And you find the elevator Anomaly, press the button from the
elevator you come from.
Yeah, from the elevator you come from.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
We're doing it.
I told you this is a team of we.
I told...
Wee.
Oh, wee.
All right.
Nice.
Fifth floor.
Chat, how many floors is this?
They don't know.
They probably don't know.
They've seen gameplay of this before.
All right.
Let's see.
Fire extinguisher.
That looks fine.
Everything looks fine.
The medicine looks the same.
Yeah, I think this floor was I think this floor was cursed
This floor is cursed What did you see?
Did you see the skeleton?
The face?
Did you see the face?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah No, I looked at the painting I
looked at this painting There was a face in the painting and
I looked at it and I was like, oh, what's this?
Oh, it showed up on my whole ass screen!
You're just, I told you, this is a we team.
What I do, you get affected.
Why is this guy just sitting here the whole time?
Why is he here?
He's like triplet.
He's moral support.
Well, he needs to be a team player, I'm telling you now.
He's the one that popped out like five minutes later, so we
don't talk about him.
What do you think?
Oh, oh.
He was in there a little too late.
Yeah, he goes extra cooked in the oven.
It's fine.
He's just the silent archetype, you know?
Oh, we're like the Huey Dewey and Louie.
Louie?
We're more like the three Stooges.
I think it's good.
I think so, too.
So we should be at the other side, then, of the elevator.
We should be on this side.
So there's no anomaly we go to the other side.
How are you still wondering about the rules?
We're on I can't remember this We're on the sixth floor.
I'm just finding anomalies, okay?
Wait, no.
Oh, yeah, I can find it.
Go back to the other.
Oh my god, I can't do this.
There's barely two rules, bitch!
It's too complicated!
What do you mean there's two rules?
It can't be complicated when there's two rules!
I thought you have what happened to photographic memory.
I didn't say I had photographic memory I didn't say that
even once.
Wait, what did you say you had photographic something?
I don't remember
Well, you know you definitely don't have photographic
memory.
No, definitely not.
I don't see any anomaly.
I don't see anything either.
Let's see one two Two, three, four, five.
Count the doors.
I counted.
There's six.
Okay.
And then the fire extinguisher are real.
They look good.
Oh wait!
There's a six on this door.
Wait, was there a six?
Was there always a six?
Six, six.
There's a six on every door.
Was that always the case?
I mean, I think so.
I can't remember.
Wait.
Chat!
Do your part!
Yeah, do your part, chat!
This is a four-player game.
You're two.
player three and four what's the point of streaming what's
the point of streaming if you don't help out do your poor
help what are you talking about chat is this real I think
it's an anomaly has this always been here guys has your guys
is there anything on the floor no help why do they keep
saying that guys you're you guys our fucking live tag is
literally called Cedars as in back seed Where are my god
damn back seed Where's the okay back Cedars is there time to
shine You guys love telling the streamer what to do Guys
Tell the streamer what to do They said it's an anomaly Wait
which one did we come from which elevator No elf wait you're
right oh no this one this one The orange whatever has the
orange Where does it say Elp what do you mean whatever has
The orange whatever has the orange is where we came from.
What orange are you talking about?
This, the orange look up.
Do you see the orange lighting?
Oh my god.
You just say the orange.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Because it's orange.
What do you want me to say?
I said orange look up.
The orange lighting.
Oh I'm sorry.
Maybe you were in the womb too long.
Hey, I'm not like him.
And he's a good guy, okay?
How would you know?
He doesn't even talk to us.
How do you know that?
So we come here.
I think it's an anomaly.
I don't remember seeing the sixes before.
I'm pretty sure the sixes have always been here.
Right?
Chat.
Chat, if you don't help us, we're going back to floor zero.
Do you want that?
Do you want to see us back to floor zero?
The orange What does no elf mean?
They said yes It means no help I don't even know I'm just
thinking Maybe there's something in it that says no elf
They're just being stupid No don't call them stupid Now they
definitely won't help They like it They like it a little bit
Okay We're taking the risk.
We're taking the risk.
Okay.
All right.
It's time.
Oh, wait.
We could have gone to the previous floor.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
We could have gone to the...
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, we did it!
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, I'm looking, though.
Yeah, it was an anomaly.
I dare you to go in.
I dare you.
Wait, if you'd find...
Wait, there was an anomaly then.
No, because we...
Yeah.
Then what was it?
It was the six on the doors, the one that I caught.
I double dare you to go to there.
I already dared you first.
I double dare you.
By the rules of double dare you You had to I triple dare
you.
I called jinx I called jinx All right, goodbye Goodbye mint
Go up.
Wait, I get affected too?
Okay,
this is this is It's a team game.
It's a team game.
Don't ever triple, one triple dog dare me to do anything
ever again.
Do you mean I can't move on from her death?
I'm not.
Okay.
That's not fair Debs.
Debs, that is not fair.
She can hold us hostage.
That is not.
Okay.
He all F4s out of the game.
That's what he does.
okay um do you want to host it all right wait no see if you
host it like continue game and see if we go back to the
eighth floor continue does it do it oh wait wait i just
pressed continue i didn't press host oh i'm on floor eight
yeah i told you wait come here come here okay i'm here i
think okay i need okay let me let me see if how i can i'm
figuring this out get out okay Okay, I can watch your game.
Wait, you didn't click host.
You're in a single-player game.
You have to go back to the main menu.
I just press continue.
Yeah, oh, wait.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm in.
We're at level eight.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Definitely.
Yeah, yeah, no.
No, no.
No, we're not doing that again.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, no.
You know, you got an achievement where, like, I think the
game.
crashed like that was the that was the achievement yeah yeah
nice all right oh yeah there was no sixes yeah all right
hello friend all right our brother our triplet our louis our
louis louis was the silent one right i have no idea i don't
know i don't remember he we do we in the yeah they're which
you yes it's the ducks but none of them were silent yeah no
one of them was like the serial the newer duck tails the
newest duck tails one of them was like they made one of them
silent and then one of them was the sonic's voice actor and
the other one was abed abed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
we're good here i think so too i think there's no anomalies
i don't think so No, you move.
We're a team.
You move.
WrestleMania 25.
The sequel to WrestleMania, we're going to a hospital.
Real.
Okay.
All right.
10 floor.
10.
Yeah!
We're so good at this game.
We're really good at this game.
We can see all the anomalies.
I thought the doors would open at some point.
I think that's like, you know how there's a locked part?
I know the doors, you can open them, but I think, you know,
like, when you start a game, it's like easy, normal, and
locked.
I think the locked portion, you can open the doors.
Oh, okay, okay.
So I was like...
Our vision is terrible.
We have to get...
We have to get all the way close.
No, I can see it.
I think it's right.
May, June, July.
That's right.
about your health like if i'm like halfway in between it
gets like really blurry you i think you need glasses i can
see it fine are you on low quality probably the game the
game defaults to low graphics yeah because it's making me
lag anyways oh wait really yeah i opened it up this time and
dx maybe it'll help stop it stop it she's the violent she's
the violent triplet She's the one that mom had to take to
the hospital.
I have anger issues.
Wait, so do we go in this one?
Yeah, we go to this one because there's no anomalies.
Okay.
All right.
Up.
Up we go.
Eleven, eleven.
Yeah, it's my soldier genes.
She has the killing gene in here.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think that was a nominee.
I think, I don't know.
I think he should have talked to her.
I can fix it.
Okay.
One clock.
All the coffees.
One brother.
Oh!
Ah!
Don't turn it on me!
I think, I think something's happening on that floor.
No.
All right.
We're fine.
See?
Everything is fine.
I'm not letting you out of here.
Oh!
Look up.
Yeah.
We are speedrunning this game.
I think this is a fire hazard floor with all those fire
alarms.
They do.
They're a little paranoid.
All right.
Finally.
This looks like a normal time.
Yeah.
Everything looks good.
okay all right coffee gold so our brother is still here wait
there's still have there always been this many fire alarms i
haven't been looking up gamers don't look up yeah gamers
don't look i think it's wait has there i don't think that's
now i'm paranoid yeah me too after seeing like 200 fire
alarms on one one ceiling now i don't know has there always
been that's a little bit too much isn't it right i feel like
i feel like a hospital shouldn't have that many they
wouldn't do two anomalies with this many like with a bunch
of fire alarms right i mean the the fucking dev crashed our
game so i feel like that's something wait a minute this door
is huge oh you're right the doors are huge yeah or we're
tiny like how we pass like five doors every single we went
to the very end of
We went through five doors and we're like that seems normal
And we're regressing in our height in our old age But we
were focused on the fire alarms We're focused on the safety.
Oh Oh, oh, wait the door is open I triple dare dog dare you
to go through that door I did it last time You go, you go
How about we do it together as twins?
No, you baby As the twins We do this together Why did you
come with me last time then?
I did!
You did?
I saw you in the elevator!
I was about to get out of that elevator when you went in.
I was gonna...
It's not my fault you didn't wait.
Go, Doki.
Go, go, go in the...
Oh, go to the other one.
Go to the other one.
What do you mean?
There's more than one?
Yeah, another door opened.
What do you mean?
Okay, I just did that door.
It's your turn.
No, no, no, no, no.
We swap!
Go, Doki!
Whatever jump scare comes out you get it too
This is some Scooby-Doo shit Oh oh go get the other one I'm
going to go do it's your turn No go go go go go It's your
turn We do the last sword together Okay okay okay okay come
on Okay, all right, all right, all right, all right.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, oh, I knew it's the same door.
This door opened before.
It is Scooby-Doo.
Oh, it's looping.
It's looping.
I told you.
It's Scooby-Doo.
What's new Scooby-Doo?
Someone's like, this instigator mint.
Oh, yeah, it is.
I read that wrong.
Yeah, it is coward dokey instigator mint.
You're ready to, like, rip that chip.
I was like, what do you mean, coward, Vint?
All right.
Can we finally have a regular floor?
We've had, like, anomalies, like, back-to-back.
Um, it's not normal.
Oh.
It's not normal.
He's happy.
He heard some good news.
He's, like, gave her subs.
Wow, gave her subs.
We, Mint just got part of.
Oh, my God.
He's laughing.
Wait, he is.
Is this a dev?
Ew.
Is this the dev's laugh?
Oh my god, is it getting louder?
Maybe that's why he's single.
Oh, oh.
Do we win?
What's going on?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Whoa, what the fuck was that?
Baby, it was the SCP.
Yes.
What the fuck is that?
What was that?
What is that?
What's going on?
It's the SCP.
You played it.
Why is he chasing me?
Oh, no.
No.
We got to get to the elevator.
We got to get to the MC.
Why is there MC B?
Why are you relying on B?
Oh, my God.
It's really coming after you.
Wait, I can't get past.
He's blocking the way.
Oh, no.
It took too long.
I'm trying to figure this out.
I'm stuck.
I can't get past.
What if he turns around?
I'm going to...
Oh, he is not turning around.
He is not turning around.
Wait, i have to get....
You need to be in the elevator!
Oh, oh no you don't.
Okay, nice.
The statue.
We escaped from floor 66.
Oh, we're at 100!
Wait, how do we get to 100?
Oh, wait, that's the door again.
It's the door again.
Is that...
No, I don't think...
I think this is because we we've advanced now it's like a
new oh that's why oh so there's more to this yeah now we
have to memorize this floor okay there's aspirin there's a
our brother moved our brother moved he finally you know like
the american healthcare system where you have to like wait
in the waiting room for like hours he finally got it he's
next he just has to wait another five hours he just needs to
yeah he needs to wait another five hours but at least he
gets a he gets a chair now he gets a chair yeah everything
out here looks the same i think besides him i think it's the
default like uh like like oh this is what it looks like with
no anomalies i think it has to be because like we started
off on this floor okay let's look in here okay there's a big
old couch there's two chairs oh yeah memorize that with your
non-photographic memory yeah i'm going to plant wheelchair
two chairs here There's two chairs everywhere.
Two hospital beds.
Vitamins.
More vitamins.
One, two, three, four, five hospital beds.
And then it's like blue and then purple, purple.
Purple.
Blue.
All right.
We should be good.
Purple.
We're not going to remember this.
This is why Chad's here.
Chad, this is do your part.
Do your part, everybody.
Do your part.
You love hell divers, too.
Now it's time to...
It's just like hell divers.
why are you guys everybody saying no help why don't you are
your h keys broken what's going on 101 let's go okay is our
brother in the hospital room I'm gonna go check on him go
check on him I think everything looks the same out here yeah
let's see the paintings are the same the calendars this room
is haunted this room is haunted why go check go look you
baby go look go look this room is haunted no it's not yes it
is how is it hot oh
look it's your cousin it's your cousin what is he doing here
what is you are such a baby from Sheet ghost I didn't know I
didn't expect your I didn't expect your cousin to come to
this collab It's actually my face reveal.
Thank you very much You have like a fucking ghost sheet
underneath That's underneath my skin suit That's so
underneath my skin is a tomato underneath her skin suit is a
halloween costume
All right, at least I don't rot Oh, you know that I could be
like an alien tomato You're not ripe anymore See what's the
boomer code It's like boomer Get it?
Because I say boo a lot Where's the mer for it?
Where's the mer for it?
Mer Wait, did I just see something in there?
What do you mean?
Oh, we was giving me a baby now.
Oh, no, there's definitely something in there.
Oh, yeah, there's definitely... Oh, yeah, I see that.
Go.
Wait, what?
I went in last time!
No, you didn't!
I don't hear talking about it.
Yes, I did.
Chat would agree with me.
What is that?
We're going together.
As twins, we go in together.
Okay, you go first.
Okay.
We can't go... Okay.
You go first.
I'll go in after.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Oh, it's a body bag.
Oh, it's, it's like crunchy.
It is?
oh why is it crunchy why is it crunchy is he eating cereal
in there for playing the mortuary assisted again oh god
please don't all right another die again
wait so how many floors did we get to before we got to the
66 i don't remember honestly i don't remember we were we
definitely didn't do a hundred floors i think yeah oh wait
what do you hear that whoa wait another door opened oh okay
never mind it's closed yeah it's time to go it's time to go
get out of here get it if there's no one on the wheelchair
it's either a miracle or something happened if someone give
me the miracle wouldn't it be more of a miracle if they get
out of the wheelchair yeah but that means somebody just
suddenly learned how to walk and then they push a wheelchair
with.
Be like, I can walk now.
Yay!
I don't need this.
I don't need this anymore.
Throws it across the room.
Okay, I think we're safe in this room now.
Wait.
Was he always staring at us or...
Yeah, he was always staring at us.
That's our brother.
No, no, no.
No, no.
Oh, wait, oh, wait, wait.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, what is that?
Bro, why can't we have a normal?
He's gay sentience.
He's just being wacky.
He's just quirky.
That's me.
Oh, do we.
Do we?
I thought it was Huey.
I remember it.
They all, like, the names all blur together.
They truly do.
Stop punching your sword.
I'm sorry.
But you were being too slow.
I was giving you a head start.
I can't punch you anymore, I think.
You've reached your punch limit.
My punch quota.
the punch quota of the day oh another one the anomaly what's
up with all these anomalies we're speed running we're speed
running oh my god oh my god put us on speedrun.com yeah yeah
duo speedrun.com we're so fast oh you got your punch quota
back i got my punch every floor you get new quota room?
Did we get a normal room this time?
Let's see.
I don't see anything.
There's no weird faces in the pictures.
If I look at a weird face, you look at a weird face.
No.
I think this is a normal room.
I think so, too?
I think we got a normal room for once.
Why is the shadows in this so weird?
Oh, yeah, that's true.
My shadow is like Going over there.
Has it always been like 0, 0, 0, 100?
It has.
Okay, you could barely remember like...
I just looked at it earlier!
Aspirant.
Yeah, I think this is normal.
I think this is normal.
It'll be fucked up if it goes back to zero.
Oh my god.
No, there has to be like a...
There's like a hundred.
There's like a checkpoint.
Yeah.
A hundred must be like our checkpoint.
I think we did.
right i'm scared we must have done it okay oh okay nice 107
nice we finally got to see the other side the other side of
it after so long we've been stuck it there for the longest
time oh anomaly what's the anomaly what what what what what
did you see what did you see what did you see What was it?
He chased after me, Doki!
What?
He got up, he moved, he didn't need the wheelchair anymore.
There was no one there.
He ran, he was running!
He was running!
I think you didn't take your meds.
He ran out of me!
Oh, that was Doki!
Oh, wait, I mean, it wasn't.
Oh, I mean, it wasn't.
What happened?
Ben, you saw me.
What did you see?
I think we were in the hospital for a human.
You saw me.
me it was like he's chasing me oh wait there's bodies in
here there's bodies in here oh there's bodies don't you want
to see the bodies move i already saw that let me rest let me
rest
Give it up for 109!
Someone in the chat was like, I know Doki can be something,
but calling her an anomaly.
SCP tomato.
Oh my god.
Everything seems fine this time.
Sure.
Yeah.
We're not gonna check the room?
You went in there, didn't you?
You don't want to do the room anymore.
Don't worry, what happened?
I don't wanna do the room anymore.
You still love the room!
I never loved the room!
You still love going to the room!
I hate you!
Wait!
Oh, no, okay, the wheelchair is here.
It was here and it was like shaking.
Oh, so that was the anomaly.
It was the wheelchair.
It was, but good thing!
Good thing!
all right i don't think there is any i don't think so either
yeah yeah i think so which would suck because like we're
about to hit a we're about to hit yeah we're about to hit
number 110.
110 baby 110 let's go let's go yay was the light always like
this oh no that's the orange light
your own story straight you thought the person running after
you was me i don't know i didn't know what to expect may
june july we care about your health okay everything looks
normal i think so too i don't see anomalies anomalies
anomalies coffee the vending machine looks the same uh
paintings wait oh look look look look look look look come in
here and look up oh run run run oh okay we're running we're
running we're running we're running we're running we're
running we're running we under shit the rules we're running
we're running all right up we go i like how we have a retry
we're like we don't know but like i know but let's just
let's just re-roll it's like gotcha we re-roll the anomaly
let's see five extinguishers seems normal um exit seems
normal yeah paintings seem normal uh the meds are all there
because someone's still not taking their meds it's not me i
don't know there's like some yeah is something different in
here or am i check.
I mean, we all know you're crazy, but like... But am I like
crazy?
But are you like, Manhara Manhara?
I'm like, are you the good Manhara or the bad Manhara?
What is the good Manhara?
The ones that are like, she might be crazy, but I think I
can fix her.
And then the bad one was like, there's no fixing her.
There's no fixing her.
I'm just here for the wild ride.
I think we're good here.
I think so too i think so too the coffee all look the same
there's one clock there's one clock there's all the coffee
stuff um the calendars look the same yeah i think we're fine
doki makes me manhara what do you mean i i literally taught
you how to use your own steam if anybody's going manhara
okay yay floor one one two one one one i think we are going
to 666 no i think we are no way why are we at 112 floors
already at 100 yeah um maybe it'll go from 112 to like 500
or something yeah just skip two other floors the dev did not
there's no way there's no way there's enough anomalies to
make 666 floors.
There's no way.
And it'll be like next patch update, we added more floors.
It's just like the spooky...
The DLC floors.
Let's see.
I don't think I see anything.
The ceiling looks normal.
Meds are still there.
No one's taking them.
Wait, wait.
The water cooler.
Oh, look at that.
My chat's helping now.
what water cooler the water cooler what about it is it this
water cooler which water cooler oh the room oh no i even
walked up to the other ones oh my god six six six six six
just like the doors see look at that my chat is doing their
part thanks chat thanks dragons oh wait a second
Yeah, but my chat said the water cooler My chat probably
said it too And I'm just not looking Oh, so you're not
reading your chat Yeah, I'm neglecting them A little bit
right now Sorry, chat It's okay Alright, let's see They're
not so needy Not like you're going to lose Whips are, you
know, they're chill The whips are just as needy as a dragon
Stop saying she hates us Stop oh my god you're supposed to
be chill she's supposed to be chill okay no okay we care
about your health the medical center i think this is a i
think this is a fire exit exit water this seems to be an
okay room guys i think so yeah there's nothing you whoa
what's that supposed to We're here for you.
You haven't taken your meds since 4-1.
We're here for the both of us.
Maybe all the triplets are fucked up.
All right, 1-1-4.
1-1-4.
Yay!
We're doing it.
We haven't failed even once.
This is crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah, just like for VOD Watchers, skip the first 30 minutes.
Skip the first 30 minutes.
But we haven't failed one.
Okay, June, July.
Alright.
I feel like the calendar would have anomalies soon.
Because I feel like the words are going to change on the
calendar.
Oh!
There's an anomaly.
There's an anomaly?
What's the anomaly?
Go check.
See if you can find it.
Come on.
Okay.
I found it.
You find it.
Exit.
Oh, there's the devs!
Is that the dev?
I think it is.
It's the dev on this PC.
Oh, you're right!
Oh, my God!
He's watching his play!
He's actually watching.
He's actually moving.
Oh my god He tapped into He's smiling at you He's tapping
into our PC He's watching us Oh my god is this like what it
feels to like When we see our chat watch us at the panels
This is what I see When I like end the stream
No Now it's just sad One one Five Five We're here!
Okay, nice.
When are we getting another SCP?
Yeah, where's our other SCPs?
Alright.
Seems normal.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Min, we care about you.
You gotta please take your med.
Ah!
Oh shit!
He wasn't there before!
I'm just like, I did a double D.
I was like, what the fuck?
Where did he come from?
He's just there at the door.
Look, he cares about your health, man.
He cares about your health.
The shadow man.
He's here.
Okay.
This is a really tall hospital.
Not gonna lie.
I know.
How many sick people are there?
I think they have other things to worry about.
They need to make a hospital.
hospital this big.
I feel like it's like the only hospital in the country.
They've demolished all the hospital and just kept this one.
I think we're fine.
We haven't even been in here.
I don't know.
I think we're fine.
Has there always been this many plugs outlets in the
hospital?
I don't know.
I wasn't looking.
You've been to a hospital before.
Give him a hair.
Wait, he's too big!
I was going to say, he looks different!
He looks huge!
Oh my god!
He drank a lot of milk!
Brother...
Brother, we're all supposed to be the same size.
No, wait, I think we're just small.
We're small!
Wait, wait, are we getting smaller?
Are we?
I think we are!
Wait, I think we are!
We're not going to be able to reach us!
We gotta hurry back, or we're going to go back to the room!
Oh my god, we also shrunk.
Yes.
Oh my god, we like grew back up.
Oh no.
Oh, it's SCP time.
No, please God, no.
What SCP is this?
Where are you?
I'm in a, I saw a maze for a second.
Yeah, me too.
Oh no.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
There's things coming out.
Oh, oh, wait, there's bodies coming out.
Wait, what's the maze rule?
What's the maze rule?
Ah, that's not it.
Oh, that's not it.
Oh
my god.
I did it.
Run for me.
Wait, you're dead?
You're dead?
Wait, he picked, he touched me.
He touched me and I died.
Like, you just have to avoid him.
Come on, Doki.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God, there's a ton of them.
There's a ton of them.
It's okay.
Run around, run around, run around, run around, face through
them.
You're a ghost.
You're, oh, they stopped.
Hey there.
Oh.
I gamed.
I'm a gamer.
Okay, so I saw the dead end and I ran back to the dead end
because I got.
Why did you?
you do that why did you do that why did you put you put me
in a maze you might as well just say goodbye to me we have a
new room oh it's 200 we're at 200 yeah we have a new room
it's at the end this time yeah yeah yeah we know no it's
yeah it is the other door yeah it's the other door look i'm
direction this is all the normal this is the normal yeah
this is the normal and we gotta figure out the oh my god oh
there's our brothers he's finally got into the he's not even
on the exam table he has a bullet in his neck he has a tumor
in his neck oh my god oh my god brother brother brother
brother what up brother no brother no this is how we find
out no at floor 200 oh my god brother is that a bullet or a
tumor i can't tell what is that kind of looks like a bullet
i think he got shot in the neck it's like he can't speak
brother no They got his throat.
No, brother.
You have to talk to us.
Brother, brother.
Brother, we're worried about you.
But the doctors, you just need to wait 10 more hours and the
doctors will be here to help with the surgery.
It's just a bullet.
Don't worry about it.
Don't mind the fact that we're in the, don't mind the fact
that this is where all the dead bodies go, brother.
It is possible to save you.
Yeah, why is the morgue in the same place?
yeah okay oh yeah assistant we're back baby we're back so
these there's three open okay one no there's four you forgot
this one oh i'm sorry for the details that i wanted to i
wanted to provide the details i mean if we're like looking
at okay if then it's not for it's five six open it's six
open if you want there we go there we go yeah that's what we
what we're here to spot the anomalies i really like that
they kind of try to spruce up this room with oh yeah plans
to be like you know you might be dying but at least there's
like something to look at and the the smiling the smiley
face right here everything's okay everything's okay you're
not is this oh no it's french su us electric say um yeah you
like my french it's authentic oh sorry sorry you don't know
you don't know that you don't even speak french
ah we uh
That's how you say doki in French, by the way.
Doki.
You can call it doki.
It's like, Oh, my name is Toby Fox.
Yeah, let's say that.
All right, let's see.
Oh, this is apparently CPR because they're kissing.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're kissing.
We're gonna do that to our brother.
Exit.
Liberation and execution.
We're gonna kiss the bullet away.
We're gonna suck it out of his throat.
Like a vacuum key, we're like...
That's what brothers do.
They suck the bullets out of his throat.
Get yourself a true brother.
That'll suck the bullet out of your neck.
If you don't kiss your brother, for him to leave, you're not
a real brother.
That's true.
Wait, was that always there?
the yellow sign thing?
Oh, I don't know, actually.
I think so.
Was that always there?
You sure?
Um, there's an anomaly.
Oh, okay.
Why are you running backwards?
Oh, my bad.
Why did you run forward?
Wait, wait.
Okay, guys, he said he didn't die.
Like, Someone you didn't even see the body bag.
I literally said there's an anomaly.
I literally said Oh, there's an anomaly and I saw it first
Yeah, but you stayed there No, I literally you pushed it
back into the I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't think I pushed anybody back That is that is he say
she says Sally sells cheese shells at the store Like that.
What's the real one?
What is it then?
What is it?
Sally sells seashells by the seashells.
She says seashells.
Sally sells seashells by the sea.
I'm sorry.
I was an ESL class as English is my first language.
English is your first language.
Yeah, I was put in ESL when I was younger.
doctor says i'm special you needed it you needed it clearly
i think this floor is good yeah i think so too i don't think
there's any anomalies two oh three yeah yeah that took a lot
longer it was like actually like deciding if we should we
give do we give her that one do we need it to give us the
point come on they're like i don't think they actually
figured it out i think i heard something but inside the room
i don't know it sounds like flickering lights or something
we care about your health may june july this calendar has
been the same thing over and over again over and over again
when is there like something new on the calendar brother
brother why is there still bullet in your neck please talk
to us brother that's all we want from you we just want you
to talk to us we miss you brother we miss your singing
brother the meds are fine i think everything on this floor
is fine the coffee is fine the clock still says six thirty
six six there's no sixes on the doors i was like why is my
chat doing smiley is but it's because yeah this is important
yeah all right up we go two oh four four four four two oh
four two oh four yeah and then we see the the elevator like
dropped down the zero i know i would like literally cry we
went through the maze Oh, anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
Come on, let's go inside.
No, we gotta see it together.
I saw it, I saw it.
You go see it.
Oh, no, he's sad.
No, he's sad now.
He realized it's terminal.
Oh, well.
We can have another brother.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, what happened?
Whoa.
Let's go.
on with you i'm letting my issues out because my brother's
dying come on come on dokey we gotta leave the elevator we
gotta go find the elevator come on yeah that's why cat hit
me back on the back into the elevator now i'm in the corner
yeah yeah let's see oh he's happy again jk oh wait what the
fuck is that oh go in i saw i go in go in what's the anomaly
go closer closer to it No, why don't you get closer?
No, why don't you get closer?
You found it.
You should get closer.
That's not the rule because last time you didn't do that
either.
What are you talking about?
We do it together.
We're a team.
That's all we have now.
Our brother is dying.
What are you doing?
Come on.
Get over there.
I don't think I could smack you anymore.
You reached your quota.
Well, I get closer.
Wait.
It's just a man with a brain.
Yeah, but it's the opposite of us.
Is he like clipping through?
Oh, he died.
brain I can't actually can't tell if it's like a head let's
it's like he's like clip through yeah that's what I'm saying
he was like clip through all right come on let's get closer
let's get closer come on what do you want to say hi I think
he's just smiling wait I don't think even is that brain or
is he wearing like a handkerchief on his hair yeah oh it's a
handkerchief it's a handkerchief i was like wait a minute
that looks like cloth i can't believe it come after us yeah
he was just saying hi really like sinister yeah he was just
like hey that's what he does on his free time all right okay
it's your turn to go to that room i'm gonna look at the
other anomalies oh i found the anomaly oh okay Never mind.
Why am I?
Come on.
Why can't we do this together?
What do you mean?
What am I?
Wait, what am I?
Come on.
It's an anomaly.
Come on.айse it.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, that's just a kid.
It's just a kid.
It's literally just a kid.
They get, like, like, Kid PNG on Google.
No, it's a kid.
It's like, just a kid.
Just a child.
What are you doing?
It's like a doctor's, like the children's hospital.
They put it in to make it seem more friendly.
They put a child in the in the lights It's like a skibbity a
skibbity.
Oh, no.
I thought you were a this is one like boomers try to relate
to the young people They just say you hate kids They just
say random things You can't just say skibbity all the time.
Don't you my god.
You can't just go
in there.
I dare you What do you mean I dare you?
Oh, what the fuck?
Go in there.
I took on Juple Dog there.
Come on, go in there.
You had a chance to live!
Oh, you met your punch quota.
Don't make me punch you.
I know you met your punch quota.
Oh, it's back up.
Okay, I guess.
I guess I can go in there.
I mean, if you insist, if you win.
Is it working?
Oh my god.
It's like a triple-day dog dare you to jump over that cliff
right now.
You were too baby.
You couldn't even go in You couldn't even go in.
Oh, yeah, as the blades are rolling down.
Oh my god, you're too baby I went in I went in the door
shut.
It was like so crazy.
Well, it wasn't you went in I punched you in Yeah, that's
really true This these rooms always have the anomalies.
They're kind of crazy.
Yeah, I think it's because like I think like the devs ran
out of ideas for the main area I just put it all in here
now.
Maybe we've exhausted all of them.
We've seen all of them.
They're like, please leave the hospital.
We're done here.
I don't think there was an anomaly.
Did anyone see anything?
Water.
I think...
I'm triple checking.
I'm going to go look at this sign, the caution sign.
I'm going to look at the painting again.
I think it's done.
Wet floor.
Water.
This floor is always wet.
Where's the fucking janitor?
What do you mean this floor's always wet?
always wet there's a wet sign it's been here since the
beginning why is every floor wet wait no we're not what do
you mean has this page always been like peeled off what page
this one has this page always been peeled off i think so i
don't think they would do something that subtle okay no it's
this
six six six Get 666.
Never get 666?
Is that what it says?
Yeah, you would never get...
Oh, you will never get 666.
Oh, yeah, we're going to prove you wrong.
We told you this was a 24-hour stream.
Oh, my God.
It's actually going to go to 666.
I told you!
This is for 666.
You know, I honestly thought this was going to be a short
game.
I thought so too.
Because I was like, I mean, like 20 floors, just like the
exit 8.
But we're actually going to 666.
But we, like, jump a lot.
That's true.
You found it?
Isn't it the plants?
Were you big punching me back in?
We're both looking at the anomalies together.
Yeah, I'm finding them.
I'm finding them.
I found all of them.
I found every single one so far.
You haven't even found them.
Come on, this is a wee game, Doki.
You have to help.
You were like, oh, I told you.
I told you.
Okay, okay.
You think there's no anomaly?
I don't know.
I think there's no anomaly.
Oh.
Did you find an anomaly?
No, I think there's no anomaly.
I don't trust you.
I'm going back.
I'm going back to cover your tracks.
Is there an anomaly in this room?
Yes!
What is it?
Can you tell me what the anomaly is?
The X-ray!
Yay!
Can you say X-ray?
X-ray!
The X-ray in French.
say that again can you say la x-ray in front of x-ray up we
go oh my god you're like boots and hondora
okay i think all the anomalies are just in that room
I'm like, I'm like, boom, all right, jump.
We didn't even say anything.
We just started.
Hey, at least I run out of the elevator.
You just walk out.
You crawl out like a baby.
That is not true.
I was hydrating.
No, no, no.
You're waiting for me.
You're waiting for me to run into anything.
No, no.
Oh, you're not even coming to this room.
with me you know who's the baby now i thought that was you
again i thought somebody was running at you again okay i
don't think there's an anomaly this time we don't know yet
we don't know yet i'm pretty sure like nothing in any in
like the outside yeah i think like all the stuff is now and
just in this room hey that makes it easier it really does
and in before they add like they actually add one anomaly
outside.
Is there anything?
I really don't see anything.
I don't see anything also.
My chat was like, look up, but there's nothing up top.
Oh, are we supposed to look up?
Gamers don't look up.
Yeah, guys.
If somebody adds stuff upstairs, then they're not real
gamer.
They're a poser.
Check behind the standing whiteboard.
You know what?
You're right.
I was looking What?
There's so...
Okay.
When you look up, they keep saying look up.
Stop, don't fight.
I am not up.
They said look up.
I'm looking up.
There's like something up top.
Are they gaslighting us?
I think they're gaslighting it, yeah.
There has to be.
Everybody say look up.
No, they're saying gamer subs.
Oh, yeah.
Check out our gamer subcode, don't keep it.
It's going boomer.
Oh wait, there's no, I think we're good.
No, no, everybody keeps saying look up.
I don't know, they're fucking with us.
I don't know.
They're not telling that to me.
I think they're fucking with you.
Oh, okay, yeah, you're right.
You're right, I think so too.
So I guess there's no anomalies.
Right?
All right, yeah.
Yeah.
Everyone keeps seeing the smile.
What smile?
The smile in the room.
No, let's go back and look at the room.
I can't.
They're saying they missed it.
They're yelling that I'm blind.
What?
They're saying we're blind.
My chat is not saying that.
Are you sure you're not looking at your chat?
I am looking.
There's nothing here.
What is your chat saying about my chat?
They're saying she's...
getting gaslight.
Everyone's saying the smile.
What do you mean by the smile?
Where's the smile?
Don't punch me.
Don't take your impression.
What are you saying about the smile?
What are you talking about?
It's Doki.
Dragoons, SMH.
So true, chat.
So true.
Dragoons, are you really going to let the whist say that
about you?
Fight, fight, fight.
And you know, like the meme, the Simpsons meme with the
monkeys fighting, and then like the people surrounding him
with money.
Okay, we're going to level 12.
Okay.
It's going to be level 12.
212.
Okay.
Oh, I was getting gaslighted.
You again.
Don't take it out on me.
I kept dragons.
You're really going to let the wisp do this.
this to you.
The wisps are good.
May June, July.
We care about your health.
Wait a second.
Oh, no.
What?
Oh, I thought something was different.
I think everything, yeah, I think everyone looks the same.
There's outlets here.
Sun, us, electricity.
Wait?
We're the same height.
Oh, never mind.
We're the same height as our brother Yeah, everything looks
the same.
Oh!
Wasn't this on the other side?
No, it was always there.
Never mind.
Yeah, the cart was always there.
No, I meant this.
Oh, the chair?
No, this, this, whatever this.
No, this was always here.
Never mind.
It was always here.
Hmm?
I was thinking about this thing, like the little camera
thing.
Gaslighting yourself.
You can't trust nobody, not even yourself.
These games make you paranoid, man.
And they were like, where's the anomaly?
Where is the fucking anomaly?
But like...
Everything looks the same.
Yeah, I think so.
I don't think there's any difference here.
It looks normal.
Yeah, this looks normal.
I guess we go.
All right, here you go.
Are the tiles bigger?
I don't think so.
Can we look up?
I'm looking up!
I looked up!
I looked up.
We're good.
All right, here you go.
Next floor.
Yay!
2-13!
Wait, people are saying there was an extra light switch.
Uh-oh.
Don't say that.
2-13!
See, Yorke!
Yes!
What the hell?
The Rizzo's deadlighting you too!
Oh.
I found the anomaly.
I found it too.
Yeah, let's go.
Okay.
I don't want to go in that cold.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think our brother's getting to his operation right now.
They're removing the bullet.
That means it's been five hours.
Yeah.
he went through two different rooms i don't even know what
light switch they mean i think they just made it up oh these
two oh so there's always been two brother did they take off
take away the bullet i think they did i think he looks a
little happier now i'm pretty sure yeah you see that smile
oh there's a cure code guys can that cure is it too like
this youtube channel i know it's getting Is it?
Oh, it is.
Yeah.
Guys, scan that QR code.
Where does it go to?
Where does it go?
Oh my God, it's fully dark now.
Where does it go, guys?
Scan it.
Scan it, scan it.
I bet you it goes to, um, it goes to like YouTube.
My affiliate link.
Yeah.
It goes to, it goes to mince gamer subs.
Someone, someone just said, I got a virus.
My chat was like, hold still.
We can't scan it because you're moving.
It's a YouTube link.
It's a YouTube link?
Is it?
Where does...
Oh, it's a Rick Roll.
It's a Rick Roll.
Wait, it has...
No way.
Hold on.
Are you going to scan it?
Is it actually a Rick Roll?
You can play it on your stream now.
It's like a five second...
It's like a five second clip.
It's unlisted.
Oh.
What is it?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's a black screen.
I can't...
I can't figure out.
Put that volume up.
I'm trying.
Hold on.
I'm going to watch it again.
Oh my God, it's disappearing.
What the fuck?
What is it?
Can you hear me?
Hold on.
I heard it.
I heard it on your end.
Okay.
What?
I can't hear him.
Wait, wait, wait, play again.
Hold on.
I'm turning off my noise gate, so.
Okay.
Hey, can you hear me?
I'm trapped in the game.
Oh, I'm trapped in the game.
Oh my god.
There's another V-Tuber in here.
I think we need to leave, though.
I didn't get out.
How dare they?
they come to our stream this is a exclusive collab yeah this
is an exclusive collab what are you trying to do coming to
our stream in our game people that chat were saying it's a
rick roll i know they didn't even bother to scan it look see
i went into the room first because i'm brave fuck you this
looks the same oh our brother our brother's been possessed
wait what do you mean stop punching me oh my god he's
looking at me he's obsessed with me brother no it's not
Alabama brother no brother no it's not Alabama brother that
bullet did things to him It's hairy.
Uh-oh.
Wait, isn't it normally at 16 that we get to the...
When do we get to the...
I think at 16, we do.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we have to get through this one.
I think everything looks same.
You say that literally two seconds into walking into the
room.
You say everything looks the same.
That's how much I need.
That's all the until I need.
It's one room.
You would have never known his brother.
Yes, I would have if I looked right at him.
I would have seen this.
You never pay attention to brother anymore, you never pay
attention to him.
Oh, yeah?
How- you were the one that was supposed to look after him
when he got shot.
I can't- I'm- You know what?
I think you were the one who shot him.
You're the one who shot him.
You played Apex!
You knew I was going to the supermarket for mom!
You knew I was going to the supermarket for mom to do- to
buy us groceries.
Cute!
Wait, I think- There's actually no anomaly.
Brother was in your care when this happened.
Now we're trapped in the haunted hospital.
We only call him brother.
He doesn't even have a name.
Brother.
It's because he can only say brother, so we named him.
We named him out.
He's like a Pokemon.
Yeah, he was like, go brother, go.
Brother, brother.
Brother.
There's no nominees, right?
Yeah.
I don't think so.
It's like the Sean situation all over again.
Sean!
Brother!
Press F to brother.
Uh-oh.
Are we about to go into the SCP world?
SCP time.
Oh, God.
2-17.
Wait!
Wait, fuck that!
Brother.
This was your fault.
No!
Wait, we go back?
Hold on, hold on.
There's 16 floors again!
No, no, no, no, no.
What if it goes back to, like, 100?
we can just go back up again what does it go up oh um what
did you do i what did you do
when an elevator just gives us question marks i don't think
that's a good sign okay you go wait the elevator doors close
on the other end yeah what did you do I'm going.
Why is the elevator closed?
Brother?
Brother, what did you do?
Brother, what did you do, brother?
Boy, are you not going inside, brother?
I don't see anything in here.
Is it like patient zero?
Are we back to zero floor?
Is that it?
Someone said we're checking your mistake.
Oh!
This is a test floor.
This is the test floor.
Wait, no.
Why did we mess up?
The scale?
The scale was never here before, right?
I thought it was.
I even looked at it.
You can review the floor.
No, this is a test floor.
Oh, wait.
Or, like, the floor that we messed up?
Yeah, I think this is the floor we were just at that we
messed up.
Oh.
What did we mess up on?
Everything looks...
Oh, it was.
The scale was never there.
What?
Oh, no!
No, I found it.
I found it.
oh they're sad at our mistakes yo this is so messed up
that's so messed up we have to do oh we have to do six okay
no it's a fast speed run because they're all in the same
room it's always in that room that's true yeah yeah yeah we
can do this all right come on we can do this come on we can
still get into speedrun.com oh oh okay we just spammed it
200 okay go oh 200 we got it speedrun my screen went black
oh no wait can you see anything I can okay all right is
there anything in there do you think it's gonna be the same
stuff as before I feel like it's just randomized all right
well that means we know what to look for right yeah we've
seen majority of it we've seen all 16 yeah we should know
what to do yeah right yeah all right so next floor next
floor oh wait 200 is always the test floor remember that oh
there's nobody nothing here there's nothing here we're sorry
we fucked up so we reverted time oh my god brother we're
sorry we messed up brother oh don't push me in is it the
what floor is it it's the saw is that we had oh he looked up
yeah i looked up i wasn't a gamer all right brother all
right we're going to get you out of here brother why are you
pushing better get you out brother brother is possessed all
right brother is possessed let's go speed run speed run no
why is it 16 i can't believe on the last floor we fucked up
i know right on the last fucking floor that means we have to
check the behind the thing every time yeah obvious oh uh the
guy is in the handkerchief guy yeah maybe they'll give it
give all of them to us maybe all 16 is just anomalies i
can't believe we know every single anomaly now.
I mean, it's easy because it's like always in that room too.
Where's the replayability?
uh oh oh go go go go go go go go go go go go the body bag
what is the body bag yeah i know where it starts at though i
know where it starts at all right uh the x-rays are upside
down all right i'll be the elevator pushy okay we'll take
turns we'll take turns you go next You're faster.
I think you're...
No, no, no.
I think you're kind of special.
I think you're really good at this.
Okay, now you go and I'll press the button.
What if I mess up?
Just go.
Go hurry up.
I run in there.
Oh my god, why are you so slow?
We know what everything is.
You literally make me do this!
If you're gonna make me do this, I'm gonna do it my way.
Check behind the whiteboard.
No, there's nothing out behind the white boy.
I don't trust you.
Oh, yeah, you don't trust me.
Look at that.
You don't even trust me to do your job.
Okay, I think we're good.
See?
At least I'm meticulous.
I look at these details.
No, we gotta go the other side, right?
Yeah, we gotta go, yeah.
I was testing you.
I was testing to see if you remember.
Oh, that sucks.
now we have to run all the way to the other side.
I know.
Yeah, because what if there's an anomaly?
207.
Don't worry, I'll be here.
What if it's the body bag?
Wait.
Why am I going?
Because then we know if there's an anomaly.
Okay.
It is a very far run.
It is a pretty far run.
I'm scared of being in here.
You're peeing in here?
Beeing in here?
Wait, I think, uh, I think we're good, actually.
Oh, no, that's the QR code.
It's the QR code.
Oh, it's the QR code.
The guy who's trapped.
See, look, it would be a waste of time if I ran in there,
too.
I'll get out of my way.
How did you know?
How did you...
I said being, you guys.
It's Doki that brought up the pee.
I can't believe it.
Why do you always bring up the pee?
You go.
Why?
Run.
Because we're taking turns.
I did not agree to that.
I hope it's the body bag.
If it's the body bag, we're going to do this all over again.
We don't.
You just run over here.
What if I die?
Go inside.
Oh, it's a sad face.
He's sad.
Oh, okay.
Sad face.
Yeah, he learned it was terminal.
So we have to, we have to get a specialist.
One of us is going to get the body bag.
It's like Russian roulette, but with a body bag.
It's your turn.
Did you get the body bag?
I sure hope not.
I know where it's at, though, in the beginning, so...
It's not fair.
Wait, that's not fair.
You know where it's at.
I'm not going to tell you either.
Wait a second.
What?
I'm sure it's not the child, too.
Um, not the child.
I don't see anything, actually.
Oh, okay.
Check behind the whiteboard.
I did.
Okay.
Are you sure?
I don't think it's anything.
Yeah, it seems good.
Let's go.
If we fuck up, we know who to blame.
Oh, you could have checked.
You literally could have taken the two seconds to go in
there.
I don't doubt you like you did to me.
I trust you.
Your turn.
All right, my turn.
Go in, go inside, go inside, go inside I'm going in Nope,
there's nothing there Behind the whiteboard I checked the
whiteboard Check for the 666 I checked the 666 There's
nothing here Are you sure?
Oh, you don't trust me again?
There's no baby face?
No baby face?
Oh, oh, you're coming inside the room too?
Wow, I'm like right next to it.
Wow, you don't even trust me.
No, I don't.
I literally, I gave like full commitment to all your
sources.
I was like, yep, you said there's nothing in there.
All right, I don't even need to check.
Okay, because it's so long gonna be on the far side of the
room, I think we should go in the next one together.
All right, you know what, let's, yeah, I agree with that.
Yeah, we'll go in the next one together.
We'll do that together.
See you guys, this is what friendship is.
This is teamwork is dream work.
All right.
Okay, let's go.
I'm there right beside you.
Okay, I'm just making sure.
Yeah, hey, why are you looking back?
Why are you looking back?
If you fully trust me, you wouldn't look back.
Oh.
Okay.
We got to give brother his privacy, you know?
We got to give him his privacy.
He's getting operated on.
He's getting operated on you guys.
Yeah, guys.
in it right now our brothers won't look okay let's go again
together together together together why did you keep looking
back huh i think it's the body bag i think it's the body bag
i think it's the body bag it's not the body bag it's not the
body bag uh there's no child i hope it's nothing so that we
can get closer to the room yeah me too i don't think there
is anything i don't see anything looked up oh whoa thanks
for the raid who i don't know who raided me brother thank
you thank you thank you all right i'm going backwards i
think we're good i think we're good yeah yeah yeah brother
brother don't worry brother we're gonna make it to two to
the 300 floor
yay oh blaze thank you 13 Now we took turns again.
Oh, it's the child's face.
It's the child, okay.
God damn it.
Okay.
All right, good.
Together, guys.
No, it's not like you.
It's all you.
What happened to Together?
Go on in.
Oh, there's no body bag.
Oh, you don't trust me.
You every time I say.
Next up, die in a body bag.
You go, Ryan.
It's 666.
It's a 666.
I think the next one's the body bag.
The next one has to be the body bag because we really have
to laugh.
Oh, my God, no.
It's okay because if it's the body bag, I can see it from
here.
It's your turn.
I'll let you know immediately.
I'll be next to the button.
It's the body bag.
at least we're on this side you know yeah okay this one has
to be the smiley then right because we haven't got behind
the boy oh my god that's so cheap the last floor with the
smiley to make he must have done it so that the last floor
was always be like the smiley face to make you think there's
nothing oh scp time no no no no oh what's happening what's
that what is that i can't see I can't see anything.
What is that?
Oh, it's like the Unity Store zombie.
But there's like a guy blocking the door too.
There's two of them.
There's two zombies.
Okay, wait, we gotta split up.
This way, this way, this way.
Okay, I got those, okay, the zombie's chasing me.
I'll sacrifice myself to you.
What do you mean, shit?
I got started chasing, getting chased by a zombie.
Oh no, they're coming after me.
They're coming after me.
Matt, this is up to you.
He's running.
Run me!
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you walking dead meat.
What do you mean?
You let that guy kill me.
I literally watched him thumb rush you.
Oh, we have a new floor.
We have a new floor.
All right, time to see you.
Here we go.
What's all different in this room?
Okay, he's over.
This is a test floor.
He's a doctor now.
He's a doctor.
He's finally getting his diagnosis.
Wait, oh gosh.
This is going to be so bad.
We have to check behind these curtains.
Oh, no.
There has to be somebody behind these.
There's going to be something on the computer.
There's going to be people behind.
Oh, God.
Okay, so he's waiting for the doctor to tell him what the
surgery was like.
If the surgery was a success.
A success or not.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the operation time.
Post-operation.
Brother, we're here for you.
Just remember.
We're holding your hand, brother.
We're here for you, brother!
Flashing your hands, drying your hands.
Isn't that, like, kind of unsanitary?
The hand dryer?
The hand dryer next to...
Yeah, I think the hand dryer doesn't do as well.
But they're trying to...
Those have, like, so many germs in them.
That's true.
And then, like...
He's pregnant?
Our brother?
Congratulations, brother!
The bullet was actually a baby.
Baby!
Ty!
You're gonna be a mother!
First ever throat birth You don't feel care Paul You cough
on a child I just noticed this room is like in the middle So
no matter what we have No matter what We have to run over
there 301 I can't believe this is actually 666 But it's
really like Oh my god brother scared me It's really like
It's like 16th floors each I think it's 15 technically
because the first oh I see the anomaly wait what oh what the
fuck their babies is this what this is baby it's the oh my
god it's triplets
it's actually how you're ready at the elevator yeah because
we saw the babies I'm not ready for that you're not ready to
be an uncle I'm not ready to be a mom uncles now we're
uncles brother i can't believe it congratulations brother
it's like how like triplets are like predisposed to like
wait what what is that you heard that did you hear that yeah
it's like i heard that check behind that's one of the wait
i'll go right side okay and also go the left side what do
you mean also i i chose my curtain i chose my My curtain is
your turn.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Okay.
Rock, paper.
What are you?
Okay.
Go check.
Oh, I heard it again.
I think it is in there.
Okay, I got an idea.
Oh, I can't jump.
I was gonna, like, jump over here and look over the curtain.
Together.
We're all we had.
This is for you, brother.
It keeps, I think it's saying here.
oh it's like okay i'm curious there's nothing here wait what
oh it's just going okay all right so we're fine we're fine
but that has to be anomaly right yeah that's an anomaly yeah
that counts that counts up is it up okay they all them
always say look up it's on the computer no oh i heard
another noise too he went wow i think it's just the same
thing you just you're just projecting
Hey, Dev, if you need anybody to make noises for you.
Thank you for the raid!
We'll do it for free!
I didn't catch who it was.
Thank you!
All right.
Where do you go?
Thank you so much.
Oh.
I don't think I see anything.
I'm checking by...
You looked for a tool.
Two seconds.
Oh, wait.
Was this computer always on?
Oh, I see something.
Oh.
Whoa.
It's kind of, that's a cool effect.
That's cool.
That is actually a cool effect.
Whoa.
Look at all these eyes.
Oh, they blink.
Whoa.
Yeah, they're pretty neat.
They gave me goosebumps.
They were blinking.
You stare at it too low.
I was just wondering my tropophobia.
Tropophobia warming me.
All right.
Three.
304 304 Alright Please Yeah, go ahead, go ahead Go ahead Go
ahead, go ahead, go ahead Go ahead, go ahead I'll go right
side Nothing on the right Nothing here Oh wait, I have an
anomaly what's the anomaly they're playing it's like a maze
escape game yeah they're playing they're playing this game
wait is it gonna show us wait it's going to the room that's
our room wait oh i don't want to see that wait are they out
here are they you think there's someone out here no no
they're in our room now oh they're looking at the anomalies
oh and it stopped the game stopped oh okay oh they're not as
gamers i yeah yeah they would they they got too scared and
stopped playing the game never skip.
We made it to 305.
We are the first YouTubers to make it to 305.
Are we actually?
What do you think?
Don't lie on the internet, don't we?
Don't.
Look, don't.
Here, I'll go right.
Okay, I'll go left.
Nope, no anomalies.
Anomaly.
There's an anomaly on the computer.
What is it this time?
Oh, hey!
There's like insert your OC.
What are you talking about?
That could be you.
Those like drawings where you buy art and insert your
character here.
And the black screen is like the character.
What?
Did we see the same thing?
Yeah, I saw it.
There was a black character out loud in there.
It's a silhouette.
Why Cee H?
Your character here.
I didn't see that at all.
What did you see?
I think you need to take your mask.
What?
No, I think you need it.
My I saw the same thing.
Why do they...
Okay, I'll go left.
No anomalies here.
Unless you don't...
Yeah, what the hell is dopey cooking?
I don't know, Matt.
She's overcooking.
Oh, you don't trust me.
You're looking at the left side because you didn't even
trust me.
Okay, well, look at the right side.
I think we should both double check our answers.
No, we don't.
Was the needle always this huge?
What needle?
I don't think there's ever been a needle.
I'll be honest.
Oh, wait.
there always been like the disease the disease history yeah
with the wait maybe we should pay attention to this yeah
maybe yeah i feel like we should wait has there always a
history has that history okay it's always been here okay
okay okay it's just his brother this doctor is just
illiterate i think we're good i think we're good too yeah
history see my chest said was always there someone said the
plant what do you mean the plant the plant no the plant has
always been that green 307 yeah yeah i hate it when it like
pauses after a while i know right and it's just like what
you mean it's ping ray brother brother right side right side
safe right side safe
Safe.
History.
Floor nothing.
Ceiling nothing.
Brother.
Exit.
Water.
Brother.
Not pregnant anymore.
He has had the babies.
He's had the babies.
It was.
It wasn't a bullet all along.
It was like an egg.
You are king.
Alright.
What happened to the baby?
It's like being watched after these.
Yeah, they're in the baby ward.
The baby ward.
Yeah.
The ward for all you guys.
It's time.
Brother!
Still the same.
Oh!
Um...
Help me.
Help.
I'm gonna drown.
I'm gonna die.
No worries!
Get that open!
The door is gonna open!
I'm gonna die!
It's gonna open, don't worry.
It's gonna open.
It's gonna open, right?
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna have to drop.
You're doing great, sweetie.
See, I told you.
There we go.
God.
She's such an overreacting.
Those were all my whips tears when I don't start the stream.
She hates us.
Man, what an overreaction.
Was saying that she was gonna die.
You know what?
I get those.
Those.
those anomalies a lot.
I think it's because I'm not a big ass baby.
That is not true.
Look at this!
Wait, has this always been white?
The floor?
It looks wider than usual.
Yeah, it looks like extra bright.
Oh, um, you might want to get out of there.
Why?
What?
What did you see?
Wait, what did you see?
Go back in.
Okay, you have to go back in until you find the anomaly.
No, no, no.
I already found it.
You go in.
It's the floor.
What did you... Oh!
We both have to restart the game and I get crushed!
So I think the reason why it was whiter was because the
ceiling was reflecting.
The ceiling was closing in.
It was like getting brighter.
The light was getting closer to the floor.
We managed to avoid drowning.
Okay.
And getting crushed.
Okay, I went in first already.
turn okay now it's my turn to go in first brother safe
brother computer safe left side safe left side history mm
safe stream lights not crushing us sink dajobu blow dryer
still unhygienic filled with germs i think i think we're
safe brother give us a thumbs up if we're safe and before
they insert like one anomaly outside just to i know right i
feel like we should still be checking but they didn't last
time so all right this is it okay all right 311 311
yeah how are hand dryers unhygienic well if they're in a
bathroom oh you go in first this time okay if they're in a
bathroom they just blow all the the germs onto your hands
right side nothing left side safe history mystery bc ground
nothing brother still there brother nothing in his brain
nothing going on in there and we're just going through it
wow there's there's no way there's not an anomaly there's
not no anomalies still Yeah, the poopy air gets blown
around.
It's disgusting.
It's like, it's like when you're, it's like you have to
change your toothbrush every couple of months.
Yeah.
Because like, yeah, every, every couple of months you have
to change your toothbrush.
I thought it was more frequent than that.
Wait, how frequent?
Wait a minute.
How frequent is it supposed to be?
Someone said, I thought it was like every month or so.
Someone said three months max.
Okay, okay.
I was like, wait, you change your toothbrush every month?
Well, like I've been getting sick a lot.
So I've been changing it a lot recently.
Not every year.
Not every three to four years.
All right, Chad, let me...
It's like a mattress.
You're just supposed to flip it upside down.
mattress you just flip it yeah okay for those who don't know
why i had to change my toothbrush every couple of months
it's because like you know how you're using your bathroom
and you're flushing yeah yeah if it's all in the same room
you're gonna want to wait oh what wait is that alive or hey
hey what is that oh it's a cat you don't get to see the cat
there's one next to you wait what is happening oh my god
he's dying There's another one!
There's another one over here!
The universe!
There's a one under the couch too!
Wait, they're all just dying!
What's going on?
Dies of cringe.
They see us.
They're like, no documentary here.
That is a cringe.
They haven't changed their toothbrush.
So yeah, you have to change your toothbrush every couple of
months because when you're flushing, know stuff goes you're
ingesting yeah that's why you close your mouth you open your
mouth what do you mean when i brush my teeth how else do you
brush your teeth okay i thought like you know when you're
flushing you like mouth open and like oh no i just mouth
open over the seat you know
that's why that's why you gotta you gotta change your teeth
Where's the other six?
Where's the third six?
Six is here.
It's over there.
Six, six, six.
We're going to make it.
Someone's like, wait, you change your toothbrush?
Oh, no.
You don't change your toothbrush until the bristles are all
frayed?
What do you mean?
That's why I don't flush.
No!
All right.
OK.
Oh brother is huge brother is huge brother is hitting the
gym Brother I love how we could tell immediately brother
brother we're supposed to be the same size Brother you can't
take you can't drink more milk than us Yeah, how can we go?
Yo, he's been doing too much protein shakes Yeah, brother,
you've been going to the gym without us.
It's not fair Brother is going to join basketball.
He's he's he's on the hospital I think we're almost a 16.
We're at almost 16.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
He's B.
Okay.
All right.
Brother's the same height.
Oh, yeah.
No.
Oh, what the hell is that?
I think it's following you.
Does it rush over?
Oh, wait.
What is going on?
Oh.
Wait, what stab us?
I can't.
Oh, they're growing bigger.
Oh my god.
I think it's babies It's protecting the babies It's like
those Those like bears It was the brother Yeah Alright last
floor Last floor Until we're at 400 How all we have to do is
The ones we're at 400 Oh yeah definitely What do you think
is over there Oh look Let's look What is it Oh What is it
Oh, I don't want to die though Look at Let's go closer No,
there was nothing behind it There was nothing behind it Did
you really check?
You actually check?
You don't trust me?
No, I trust you I trust you I just wanted to be sure of you
check I trust you You don't trust me You always look at what
the stuff I looked at I hope you don't die this time again
Oh yeah, sorry for sacrificing My life for you What's it in
here What's it in here?
I just saw like PC monitors In the toilet Wait Oh, we have
to open the doors.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Ah!
What the fuck?
That was your door.
Wait, but we just restart.
It's fine.
Uh-oh.
Sorry.
What do you mean?
Just run away.
Oh, Skippity.
Hey.
It's Skippity.
Oh, you missed it.
Oh, this one is empty, though.
I can't believe it.
The boomer missed it.
Oh, it's flooding.
It's flooding.
Is that you?
No, that was not me.
I did not open.
Why does all the doors you opened end up killing us?
It's not me.
What do you mean it's not you?
You lit.
Every door you open.
Just keep opening.
I am.
Oh, who's laughing?
Oh, my God.
It's not going inside the...
Oh, no.
We're gonna drown.
My toilet's laughing at me.
My toilet's laughing at me too!
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
Where?
Where are you?
Go in!
Come on, hurry up!
Oh, shit.
Oh, I got in.
It's Kate.
Hurry up.
You don't even say where we're at and just say hurry up.
Like, thanks for the instructions there, man.
Wait, is this the same room?
Oh, no, we're in the toilet now.
Whoa, brother.
Our brother needs privacy.
brother oh we're gonna have to check inside every single i
don't think so oh yeah we have to look through the crevice
it's us family portrait look at family photo in the bathroom
everybody meet us meet and greet in the bathroom six toilets
there's six of everything there's even six sinks oh my god
and there's six blowdrivers you right next to the toilet
they're right they're gonna blow that into your hand.
Brother, do you have enough toilet paper?
I like how the kids sink is next to the urinal.
Okay, this one's gotta be easy.
There's like nothing in here, right guys?
It has to be.
We can speed run this to 600.
We can speed run this.
We're literally so close to the end.
200 more floors.
Yeah.
We're like masters now.
Oh my god.
We're the masters of the universe.
I don't know about that.
What do you mean?
Look at this.
The mirror Oh, don't say that.
Don't say that.
How would you know?
Check the mirror.
Oh, there's blood.
Oh!
There's more than just blood.
Those hands are, like, coming out of the wall.
Yeah, like, it's like a PNG.
He's holding a PNG of the airbend.
They're supposed to be, like, a behind the vent.
Wait, does that mean vents are fake?
Like, they don't lead anywhere?
There's no ventilation?
Wait, there's no ventilation in the bathroom?
That's not.
Hygienic at all.
Alright.
I like how we don't say anything.
We're just like...
Just like 180.
I was like, alright, that's an anomaly, right?
Don't pee.
I have to pee.
Oh.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll do this for us.
Don't die in there, okay?
Just stay there.
What if I just die?
Don't die.
Why are you still here?
Okay, I'll be right back.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, guys.
We're just waiting to see if I get it.
Oh, okay.
There was no anomalies.
Wait, has there always been three trash cans down here?
Why is there a trash can down here?
I didn't look down, guys.
I didn't...
Guys, has there always been three trash cans?
I didn't look down!
Yeah?
Wait, why would the trash cans be here?
Okay, there's always been three tracks.
Two, four.
No, we have to start counting.
Two, four, six.
Two, four.
Wait, where's five?
Two, four, six.
Okay.
Two, four,
five.
Where's the six?
There's the six broom!
Two.
Oh, there's a two, four, six.
Two, four, six.
Two, two, four.
Where's the six trash cans?
six okay there's six of everything two four five wait
there's five oh six that's a okay one two three four five
six i think we did it no anomalies no anomalies if we get it
wrong i blame chat there's a seven urinal there's a seven
urinal i don't know two there's six urinals someone can't
All right, I think we're good.
I think there's no anomalies.
Well, Min is so slow.
Of course, of course she goes to the bathroom when there's
no anomalies.
Look at her.
Was there?
Yes, there was six toilets because the whole game is based
off of six, six, six.
So there's six of everything.
Hold on, I gotta get tea.
Oh, man, don't come over here.
No, Min, there's no anomalies.
No, you can't just...
What do you mean you have to get tea?
There's no anomaly!
If only I could just leave.
Oh my god.
Oh, I could push her.
You're right.
Oh my god.
Why didn't you guys say that earlier?
I could have just pushed her.
I can't believe it.
I could have done that in the very beginning.
I messed up.
Wait, no?
Okay.
There.
All right.
We're getting you to the other side.
Nice.
We did it.
We're professionals.
Okay, I gotta, like, make sure.
Okay.
In case there's an anomaly.
Or there's no anomaly as well.
Okay, no.
Alright, here we go.
I'm gaming.
Everything looks the same.
I'm back.
Oh my god, you scared of shit.
I had to push you to the other side of the elevator.
Because there was...
Everything looks good?
There was no anomalies.
You have plenty of time.
I'm gonna check.
I don't try to see.
What do you mean?
We're on the other floor now.
Oh, nope.
Oh, oh, oh.
No.
What do you mean?
Oh, no.
let me double check this is a new floor come on let's hurry
it up i literally pushed you from one elevator to the next
all right here we go four oh five you guys be honest i was
so brave i counted i learned how to count today i learned my
abcs you took your counting medicine yeah i took my counting
medicine i just realized we had to count these items as well
because i also Yeah, how many trash cans?
Six.
Okay.
Yeah, it's six, six.
Oh, seven.
No, there's seven.
Two, four, six.
What do you mean?
You're six.
Someone did learn to count.
It's me.
I didn't learn how to count.
Someone didn't learn.
Wait, let's look at every single little style.
Two, a four, six.
I think we're good.
I think we're good, too.
I'm pretty sure I think so back to kindergarten Mint didn't
take her counting medicine That's okay Send me back to
kindergarten Let me be a child again Alright Yay 406 406 406
Trying to get me out of here That's pretty impressive You
were able to punch me all the way Yeah I'm trying
What was that?
It was that blow dryer.
Oh, what was that blow dryer?
It scared me so bad I couldn't even make a noise.
Yeah, it's just like, well, shit, I thought it was something
chasing us.
We talked too much shit about the blow dryers, guys.
Ugh.
Okay.
All right, we're still normal.
There's going to be something in here.
Four, let's test her counting.
Two, four, six.
Two, two, four, six.
Oh, we have to make sure to look between the toilets, too.
I looked in between.
Why is this toilet, like, filled with...
Was there always a toilet in here?
Yeah, this is, like, the handicapped slot, too.
Yeah, because it's a bigger stall, yeah.
That's so messed up.
They did not care.
This is a hospital.
There's so many people in wheelchairs.
Yeah, there's so many people in wheelchairs.
And yet they filled it up.
Look up.
I'm looking up.
I mean, we counted everything.
There's six lights.
Two, four.
Wait, no, there's eight lights.
Has there always been eight lights?
I don't think it's that meticulous, right?
I don't think so, either.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a bloody handprint.
What do you mean, bloody handprint?
Everybody's spamming handprint.
Handprint?
Is it in the toilet, maybe?
Does anyone spam handprint on your chat?
There are four.
lights what do you mean there's handprint by the kids urinal
there's a kids urinal there's a kids i don't think there is
they're just saying that the fuck with us oh oh that's not a
urinal that's that's funny what wait there's also like a
hand down there yeah there's something in the trash can wow
that's sneaky oh that was a sneaky one is it a hand i think
it was i'm pretty sure it's a hand We're not short enough to
see it.
We're not a chat.
We now know someone in the chat pees in sinks.
Someone uses the kid's urinal to pee in the sink.
I don't think this person's allowed near the kid's hospital.
Someone's peeing in sinks over here.
Oh.
In public urine.
What if you stand there?
I dare you to stand there.
Stand where?
Over there?
wait there's a shadow over there i triple dog dare you i
already dared you it's gone oh it's gone oh it's back oh
it's back that's your turn okay oh it's gone you like
absorbed him yeah yeah you too all right you oh it didn't
move it back any further though yeah it's just there all
right anomaly we're so good at this i know we're like
professional anomaly hunters even yeah we didn't get help
from chat at all like yeah we got like we've like never
failed we literally have never failed yeah we've had we've
been consistent throughout this this game is just a really
long game oh why do you run past the door why do you say oh
brother brother it's a miracle brother has risen on the
fourth day he rises Oh my god, guys!
Metal Gear Rising?
Oh my god, it's a miracle, guys!
Why do you always run?
Oh, okay.
Someone peed in the urinals for a minute.
Someone actually peed in the urinals.
They mixed the juices up.
What do you mean by that?
Only bros understand.
I don't think even bros will understand what you mean.
bros no
All right, let's see.
All right, little brother.
Don't run past, just run.
Just run inside.
Wait, there's something weird Something weird.
Look, look.
Oh, yeah, you see that.
The caution signs are moving.
Yeah Wait, they're coming.
Wait, they're coming after us.
Oh, wait, the rats are coming after us.
Yeah, yeah, right?
Wait, what would the caution signs do?
Wait, let's see But what if we die does like with what
converging they're converging it's like a like mating ritual
oh we're watching a mating ritual right now oh nope oh i
told you it does nothing i'm not their mate i'm not their
mate come on it was a mate i think they'll block the
entrance oh maybe yeah i think they're gonna block the exit
all right the floor is wet oh my god maria thank you for the
rain the floor is wet The floor is wet.
From all the juices in the urine.
Yeah, your words.
See, I told you you knew what it means.
I knew it.
See?
She knows what it means.
Don't run past the door.
Just go straight in.
Don't run past.
I've always walked in.
I don't know what you're talking about.
She's rewriting history right now.
She's rewriting history.
history two four six there's six trash cans i think it's no
anomaly i think this one's good i'm looking up there's
nothing in the mirror up or they know yeah they've always
been up it's a men's urinal the urinal the urinal i mean
it's a men's bathroom i guess uh doors are cracked there's
no doors that's cracked what do you mean the doors have been
cracked yeah someone was like saw something what did you see
did you take your meds i saw something i saw you i saw
something nothing in the mirror i'm just there's six of
everything are you gaslighting no i'm not i'm not
uh-oh i think there's a biggie in here i think there's a big
one in here don't you crash oh no i'm okay now i'm okay i'm
okay oh my god it was so scary it was so scary because like
i said that and then like everything just stopped everything
stopped moving and i was like oh no what happened wait are
there more fire things than usual for i mean you can
literally count.
Was there always six?
I mean, there's six of them.
Yeah, I mean, I was like, was there always six and six, six?
Oh, my God.
That was so spooky.
Spooky.
Her stream is alive.
My stream is alive now.
Woo.
I think there's nothing here.
There's been, like, not a lot of anomalies for this one.
Not for this one, no.
Yeah.
I mean, it's, like, such an empty room.
What are you going to do?
I think, like, this is like hard harder to have anomalies i
think so too i think we're five all right oh i can't punch
you had you hit your quota you hit what happened why can't i
punch all the time how come we can't have six brothers i
don't understand we can only have five brothers but it's a
five it goes up four players where's our where's brother
four five and six we went in the wrong elevator
this was you no it wasn't you this was you this was you no i
followed you i followed you you could have stopped me you
could have stopped me you could have stopped me
no uh check if the thing appears wait but what if there's
new anomalies what if there's new ones that we don't oh wait
no this is zero this is zero it's always
Why didn't you stop me?
No, no, no, this is Chad's fault.
They should have told us.
Instead, they laughed at our jokes because we're just so
funny.
Oh, my.
Okay.
Thank you, game.
Thank you.
Don't worry, we can speedrun.
What floor were we on?
How far did we get to?
We got to 13.
We got to 13, man.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I dare you.
I triple dog dare you.
All right.
You know what?
I'm not afraid.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, my God.
I killed.
You, you murdered them.
You didn't see anything.
You cleaned up the bodies really good.
Oh, my God.
You didn't see anything.
I don't know what you're talking about.
No, I did not, brother.
Remember, there's always been three brothers.
Remember that?
There's always been three brothers.
There's never been a four, fifth, or six brother.
Oh, that is the mating ritual again.
Oh, it's the mating ritual, you're right.
Here they come, here they come.
This is why there's only three brothers.
I'm an accessory to murder.
They won't believe you.
Hey, but that was a new one.
That was a new one, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
all right we got this speed run speed run speed run speed
run speed run we have to be careful of the head though
peaking out yeah but the head i mean i'll look at it i'm
looking at it okay i'm looking at it look through the cracks
right now while we i'll check the cracks i'm looking through
the cracks i don't see anything i'm voyering i'm i don't see
anything i had her brother is still being brother this is
why he doesn't talk
he saw some some stuff he wasn't supposed to
check for handprint i already looked i already looked we all
looked here we go 405 405 405 give it up for 405 all right
here we go here we go let's see brother is so on the toilet
oh it's uh it's so loud it's so loud i never expect it no
one ever expects the blow dryers at least we got it out of
the way oh my god here we go everybody we're okay we're okay
we're almost back to 13 brother brother it's not performing
any miracles right now i'm looking what check the doors oh
whoa what the fuck he closed the door what stop looking at
them stop it how come she lets you look but i can't were you
invited to something i think so i think so but that was also
a new one that was a new one yeah that was a new one i've
never seen that one before yeah so that could have been 14
15 and 16.
Brother.
Brother's not performing miracles.
No peekaboo.
We're missing like one new anomaly.
I think so too.
Yeah.
No hands.
We can see our faces.
There's no hands coming from the vents.
I think we're fine.
No anomalies.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
See?
We're so good at this.
Let's go.
We could have been at 4500.
Okay.
We could have been at a floor.
Shut up, shut up, we'll get, we'll be there, we'll be there.
We could have been at a floor of 500.
We could have been there!
We'll be there!
We'll get there!
We'll get there.
Okay.
Brother.
Brother sitting down.
Faces.
Handprint!
All right, back to the elevator.
Bro, we got a routine going on now.
We have a system!
I know.
speedrunners we're speedrunners speedrun.com sign us up
maybe y'all why are we speed running because we because no
no because you chat messed up brothers brother brothers
brother we have faces we have faces there's no shadow oh
there's the peekaboo peekaboo all right but not you dragon
the dragons I don't mean you what chat are we talking about
what are you trying to apply what are you trying to apply I
think there's only two chats here oh brother is brother
comes after us brother brother brother runs brother walks oh
my god a miracle the second miracle like what if he came to
the door What if he was just like he was trying to talk to
us he was trying to communicate he was like brothers
brothers look at me now Brothers, this is the one time.
I'm sentient Brothers, I have something very important to
tell you Oh, it's the footprint.
Oh, it's a foot.
All right This is the one time I could say whatever it is.
I've been keeping it in this entire time Oh my god, we're
almost there back to work.
We're still missing one more anomaly that we haven't seen
before because we got uh we we were missing three and now we
saw two of the new ones yeah we need the we're missing this
one's gonna be the faces nope never mind nope um no urinals
i don't see anything there's no hands coming out of the vent
there nothing at least they don't make us count these thank
god i was not i'm not paying attention i know it's all sixes
but i'm not paying attention all right okay let's go back
where we started yeah you're right nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice nice what's this one no faces no faces no faces no
blood in the urinals no hands coming out there's nothing
another no anomaly two in a row two in a row two four six
come on ghosts you're getting a little crazy right now yeah
come on okay what is this we want an actual child this way
this way this way 414 has to be the last three has to be the
anomalies ones because we're missing the the faces the hand
hands coming out of the vent and the blood in the urinals
and the blood yeah we're missing those three okay so easy
peasy we got this guys all right which one is this Hands.
All right.
You know what?
We can literally, I bet you, you'll risk it.
We stay in the elevator for the last three.
You stay in the elevator?
Oh, me?
No, no.
I was like, no, we press the buttons.
We don't even have to look at it because the last two has to
be anomalies.
You're a coward.
What do you mean I'm a coward?
I wanted to go into the room.
You know it's an anomaly.
You even knew it.
Blood in the urinal.
I knew it.
The last one has to be the mirrors.
Okay, then you can check.
Alright?
No, I don't even need to check.
I'm going to press the button.
I'm going to do it.
How much do I want to bet?
I will bet money.
How much do I want to bet in Aka Super.
I will bet in Aka Super.
Yo, you know I'm right.
You know I'm right.
You don't want to bet.
You're wrong.
Why are you running back this way?
Why?
you're wrong you're wrong you're wrong that's why i'm
smarter i'm gonna die immediately on this one so that um oh
what where are we it's a dark closet oh my god 60 seconds in
heaven why is it so dark in there i don't oh oh no oh no we
gotta go downstairs oh yeah we gotta go i think we we like
broke our ankles I think we broke our ankles I think maybe
we don't push each other then maybe we can't actually you
can't run you can't even run I'm fucking ran and I broke my
ankle coming there's something on like I like ran and I
broke my ankle you are weak bones what happened to you oh my
god I was even watching.
Can you see what's like happening?
Yeah.
I was born with Kasparin.
There's a girl whispering.
A brief breath I take is pain.
Shut up.
You weak-willed woman.
Oh my god.
I'm so close.
I have bonetitis.
Do I just walk or oh my god.
Wait, there's a face there.
There's a face?
Where?
Look at it.
It would be so funny if you look at it again.
Oh, okay.
There's no face, you liar.
Yes, there is!
I'm the only one that survives these!
Oh, I'm sorry, my bones were made of glass!
Oh, you're gonna fucking bring up my medical history!
Brother has been demoted to being a janitor.
He's a janitor.
Okay, okay, this is always in here, this little head bag.
They're throwing away body parts.
Wait, oh yeah, this little head bag.
Why are you throwing away body parts?
Okay, I don't think...
so many there's six brooms six six brooms six the six trash
cans but there's only five sinks oh that oh i feel like
that's gonna be anomaly they're just gonna bring a six sink
out of nowhere and there's five trash cans there's five
trash cans oh because it oh because this is like floor 500
we're so close okay we have 266 floors to go we're almost at
the finish line I did not expect this game to be like three
hours long.
I didn't expect it.
Well, you know, if some chatters wouldn't, you know, give us
the wrong information.
Oh, you're so right.
Yes.
If some chatters didn't backseat us better.
Oh, oh, oh God.
I actually, I thought that actually got me.
That actually got me.
That got me too.
Wait.
That's the anomaly, right?
It started us over.
No, it's 501.
That's where we were at.
Yeah, so we go up.
That was the anomaly.
Oh, okay, then go up.
Yeah, that had to be.
That kind of got me.
I was like, I just got a new PC last week.
Like, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
And I saw 666.
Yeah, you guys, it's the dragoons.
It's not you.
Yeah, you guys, it's the Wist, don't worry.
You know, it's always the Wist.
go into the rooms oh good good good good it's both of us
wait oh oh oh brother brother brother brother brother
brother brother brother brother brother brother brother
brother brother brother brother brother okay
that was good it's johnny Johnny
Yo, that was so good That was good I like that It was the
perfectly cut rectangle in the door
Blender's rectangle Delete Alright, here we go I wonder what
it would have looked like on the outside I wonder Oh, I just
see That was a good one That was a good one You know what,
Des?
You got that.
You can have that one.
I don't think there's anything here.
I don't see any anomalies.
The bags all have one.
You neither.
Check the signs if they say any other 666.
Yeah, oh yeah.
I feel like every floor has a 666 somewhere.
They do.
Sometimes, someplace somewhere.
666.
All right.
Have you been counting all of these?
They're all five, right?
They're all five because we're on the fifth floor.
Or the 500th floor.
The dev is so funny.
all right here you go johnny goes in the square hole the
johnny goes goes in the square hole go on in there's got to
be something in here caution
nothing nothing in the bag is there always something in four
or five there's no sixes anywhere I feel like the sixes
would be like in the trash can you know something yeah yeah
like at the bottom yeah yeah yeah or somewhere i don't see
any body parts coming out i think we're good i'm going on
the other side okay we're good goodbye brother where are you
oh i was just double checking you don't you never trust me
you don't believe even though i was right i was like the
last okay if we go to 500 i'm just saying the last three
floors were anomalies and you didn't trust me you're like I
wouldn't even bet real money into it because you knew I was
right.
You knew I was right.
I was just being cautious.
Do you know your head bobbles up and down when you run?
Like actual running.
Wait, something seems different.
This?
Was there always?
No, that's a way too many.
Many plugs, right?
Yes, I think that's way too many.
Oh, there's six of everything.
Look at how this made.
There's six of everything suddenly.
Oh my god, you're right.
There's six of everything.
I like how you were like, I like how you're like, well, look
at the plugs.
I'm like, looking at everything else.
You focus on the fucking plugs.
I mean, it's the first thing I saw.
I don't know.
The tiny plugs of the first, not the giant red fire hydrants
and hoses.
Look, they were covering the wall The first thing I saw Oh,
there's a baby Oh, there is a
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm spectating The baby
The baby kills me Babies are dangerous Don't look at the
baby Don't look at the baby Don't look at the baby And you
were judging me when I killed those two girls The baby
killed me It should have killed you.
I was protecting you brother.
Oh brother's about to explode Oh my god brother's a TNT Oh
my god, what the fuck goodbye brother goodbye brother I he
was a brother to me
Brother was literally you know that meme of the guy sitting
and he's like super bright That's why he's sitting in the
middle express drive yeah see come inside what is wrong with
you i was i was waiting for you to be inside first i was
already inside you were not no you were not i was 100 no no
no check my vibe yes yes check my vibe vibe time stampers i
don't think there's anomalies here i'm pretty sure yeah yeah
all right let's go wait only four mobs i don't i think the
chat's with us
five oh nine five oh nine i knew it i knew that chat that
was way too detailed because a real chatter would be like
what uh the head is moved so like the you're sure yeah it
wasn't it's not moving now no like they're in different
positions oh where they are you sure yep oh you're right
It's moved up closer.
You're right.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Easy, easy.
Chat, I know when you're lying.
I'm so good.
I like find everything so quickly before Doki.
I'm sure.
Yeah, yeah, like the six plugs that you saw, too.
And there were actually six plugs.
I don't know why that's what you're so focused on.
Woo!
That's a lot of...
That was not six boxes.
How do we get out?
Oh, got the collision.
The collision.
I'll pitch you out.
I'm going to punch you out.
I'm going to get out.
I'm trying to get through the wall.
I can't push me.
No, I'm trying.
No, you're not doing anything.
See, what do you mean?
You see, this is why we.
This is.
Oh, I got out.
I got out.
Come on.
Yeah, but I, you need.
Oh, oh, it disappeared.
Okay.
Wow.
You didn't even try.
This is why only one of us needed to go inside If it was
just one of us inside, we would not have to You still would
have needed me No, no, I Okay, you can go then this time No,
you're in my tea, hold on Okay, you're drinking your tea, I
see I don't think there's anything here
What are you laughing at?
I'm serious, there's nothing here It's because you walk in
for a few seconds and you're like nothing near because i
have good memory unlike somebody who has got okay i actually
need chat to to keep track of who has gotten the most things
in this game yeah they'll say me wait was there a mirror
there's no mirror in there i got gas lit look okay i'm gonna
say you know when they're lying when like they get extra
detailed because like usually when they think they see an
anomaly they'll be like mirror but then they said face in
the mirror i got one guide for real you got one guide five
12.
all right here we go i hope it's it's uh it's no anomalies
there's no way doki would have gotten through this game
without me Guys, I was so good at Exit 8.
I literally had a speed run.
This is literally Exit 8, but multiplayer.
So I did that solo.
It's a different game.
This is literally Exit.
Oh, Anomaly.
See, I found it before you.
I found it before you.
Look at that.
You didn't even see it.
If I said nothing and let you pick the pathway.
That was actually really good.
I'll give you that one.
You know, I press the button, though.
Which means I found it.
If I press the button, I mean...
Where are these, like, new rules?
Like, yeah.
She's definitely in kindergarten where they invent new rules
just so they can win.
Yeah, you were blocking my view, actually.
So, like, I just couldn't see it because your big head was
in the way.
You know.
I don't think there's anything here.
I don't think so, either.
No anomaly.
Yeah?
You don't believe me?
I'm just checking.
Oh, someone doesn't believe me.
Get in there.
Oh, you press the button?
Okay.
This is your choice for no anomaly.
Five, four.
That was you.
You said it first.
Remember your rule.
Your fucking rule.
But it means that you found the anomaly.
I don't think there's anything here.
Do you know why we messed up?
We went to the wrong elevator.
We went to the orange light elevator.
No, we didn't.
No, we went to the other one, right?
We went back.
How does this happen to us?
That's what I'm telling you.
The rules are too confusing for this game.
That the orange light needs to be more obvious.
It needs to be...
That's too rough.
That it needs to be more obvious.
I'm telling you How much more obvious do they need to be
Orange night light needs to be like so bright It needs to be
They need signs They need signs where it just has like big
Like 50 It says you came here Impact font Anomaly here No
anomaly here Oh it's the bag heads It's the bag heads
We'll never I found it I found it I found it Yeah, put the
The one we fucked up It was you who fucked up Not me Oh,
yeah, someone should stay outside for Johnny You're right
Oh, yeah, you're right, you're right Alright, I'll be
outside I wanna see Johnny Oh, rock, paper, scissors Rock,
paper, scissors I think there's no anomaly There's no
anomaly Check Don't go my way i was just testing you to see
if it's like three in a row i can't believe we got we were
so close we were at 5 14.
we were so close oh my god this is why this is why this game
is gonna take us three plus hours this is why I don't think
there's an omni.
Johnny, Johnny.
Yes, Papa.
Woo!
Well, you gotta wait for me.
No, I was able to get out.
You can do.
Come on.
How?
Push the boxes.
Go outside and push the boxes inwards.
I push them outwards.
You can do it too.
Come on, just use your legs.
What do you mean I'm using?
I'm too tall.
I'm sorry for being six foot seven.
It says on my Tinder profile 6 foot 7 Well, I'm gonna wait
in the elevator For your lazy ass Okay, it's gone Alright,
here I am Oh my god I'm getting there I'm going as fast as
my 6 foot 7 Legs start taking me You have really short legs
You have the widest torso in history Alright 5-0 foot eight
more to go all right why is it always on 13 that we mess up
I know I mean 13 is an unlucky number it's a brother it's a
TNT brother it's a TNT brother go go go go go please brother
think of your children
oh all right here we go we went to the correct elevator yeah
he's a creeper Alright, don't call our brother a creep.
What's wrong with you?
Oh my god.
What are you talking about?
He has children.
That doesn't make him a creep at all.
That makes him...
Alright, I don't think there's any anomaly here.
I don't think so either.
There's no smiley.
Unless there's a new one.
Oh, that's true.
We didn't think of new ones.
But I think in general it doesn't.
There's no anomalies.
Yeah, I think we're good.
I need sixes on the... Wait, wait, wait!
Anomaly!
Oh, anomaly!
You're right.
The six, six?
I knew it.
I knew the six would come back.
See guys, remember the competition that Mint proposed where
whoever catches the most Anomalies wins?
This competition that Mint really wanted to do where she was
like, oh guys time's down every time like whoever picks the
Okay, but I'm still winning Sure in your dreams, I guess I
like how you like don't even walk inside.
No, because we wanted to see Johnny.
Oh, yeah.
How could you forget about Johnny?
He's been there for us.
Yes, Papa.
I don't think there's nominees.
I don't think so, either.
All right, here we go.
Yay, finally the closer one.
Yeah, every time there, I was like, but I feel like we're
going to get in there.
Oh, we missed it.
Wait, what was there?
Huh?
Oh.
That was you, you called it.
No, I did it!
That was you, you called it, you called it, you called it,
you called it, you called it, you called it, you called it.
We're gonna be stuck in floor 500 forever!
The door was backwards?
Wait, how, what do you mean?
How can a door be backwards?
Okay, this is the normal one, remember?
No, yeah, this is the, yeah, that's right.
I always forget.
We're gonna be stuck in floor 500!
I could tell you were hydrating before the cry.
Oh, it was on the wrong hinges.
Oh, my God.
So that's something else we have to...
We have to keep track of the wrong hinges.
So right now...
Oh, no.
Yeah, right now.
Oh, it's backwards.
Yeah.
It's backwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, good.
We got it out of the way.
Yeah, we got that out of the way.
That is such a sneaky one.
That should have been a floor 516 one right there.
Mm-hmm.
Not stupid.
People miss that too.
Yeah, everyone is probably miss that in their lives.
Yeah, everybody.
Those who called out has played this game before.
I could tell.
Johnny?
Yes, Papa?
Oh, it's all the plugs.
All the plugs?
Oh, yeah, it's all the plugs.
We're stuck in 500 forever.
We'll never get this.
He was right.
The dev was right.
We will never get six, six, six, six.
Six or stuck here forever.
It's Chad's fault.
They warned us soon enough.
They could have yelled at us.
They really could have.
They could have screamed if they knew it instantly.
I was going to say, I was going to say Aka Supa.
I was going to say so mean.
This is so cool.
It was.
Come on.
Come on, Min.
Get over here.
Come on.
Come on, Min.
Why?
Come on.
I thought you were so good.
at this i'm coming i'm coming don't push me back any
messages oh look at me i actually got out so clearly it was
just a skill issue for you oh yeah it's not like i helped
you get there look out when you punch me out what you're
talking about i helped you get there guys guys if you guys
see any anomalies make sure the akasupa
We won't miss it at all.
There's no sixes.
I think there's no anomalies.
Guys, this is your chance right now.
We're saying there's no anomalies.
This is your chance.
I'm going to look at everything really slowly.
We're going to look at this really slowly.
No anomalies.
If there was anomaly, it's not our fault.
We gave you a chance.
No elf.
help all right here we go up we go up we go bing bing 505
505 johnny johnny johnny johnny johnny what is it what if we
both have to be inside though no i don't think so because
like what if it's a solo single player a single player it
wouldn't matter yeah because they would be inside no wait
what oh yeah
Okay.
Okay, dokey.
All right.
No anomalies.
We have to go to the further one.
No.
Maybe it'll give us back-to-back no anomalies.
She's an actual bird.
What does that say about you, huh?
You messed up, too.
You have no excuse for messing up.
Not as much as you.
At least people can say I'm a bird brain.
What about you then?
I'm dead.
I have like my brain is ectoplasm Your brain is literally
mush.
Okay.
Oh smileys Smileys.
Okay back to the long one we go Back to the long one we go.
I'm gonna speed you up.
Actually you're really not doing anything
It took you to the corner I'm a quick chiropractor not
licensed all right next one guys we're so close to 513 again
we're gonna make it are we that close we i don't know oh the
trash bags yeah yeah yeah that's the bags it's the bags at
least the the shoes running is kind of asmr yeah it is you
know when it says hospital 666 i honestly thought the six
was a joke wait so do we get to like what happens do we get
to just floor six or i think no it's 666 so it could be like
613 like 615 and then all the way to 666 at the end okay all
right johnny no johnny oh oh it's the 666 okay back to the
long hallway we go you didn't even go into the room to see
the johnny what do you mean what if you have to come inside
well we have to inside i would have gotten inside to see if
we triggered that johnny that johnny that's silly guy he's
so silly i want to see him too though all right i'll go
inside we'll do russian roulette again okay okay all right
one of us has to get the baby and the other one gets johnny
oh it pushed me inside you inside we get the um pov of
johnny again front row seats Johnny, we want to see you.
We want to see your face.
Whoa!
There's Johnny.
There he is.
I like how it grew up.
Sounds like Freddy Fazbear's laugh.
Oh my god, someone asked a soup with me and said, I see an
anomaly.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Oh my god, thank you.
We would have never would have gotten...
Oh, brothers on fire, brothers on fire, brothers on fire.
That's always the long one when brothers on fire.
I don't know.
This game is...
We didn't realize when they said 666 it was literally 666
Remember when we said 24-hour street we were not joking We
meant it Oh, it's the baby.
It's the baby.
I went the wrong way don't go the wrong way Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, push me faster.
The baby baby I think we didn't look at the baby so the
baby's not coming Be gone, yeah, stupid baby.
That's why you're a baby.
You should have died.
You should have died by the baby.
Why was I?
Why was I supposed to die by the baby?
I'm not.
Because I died from the baby last time.
Yeah, but you're stupid.
Yeah, because totally I knew that looking at a baby would
kill me.
I told you I'm not ready to be a mother.
Well, I saw that Tokyo jungle playthrough.
You were so ready to be a mother.
You should play that game.
You should build.
You taught me that I killed like your little birdies.
Was there anomaly?
Yeah, anomalies?
Why are you just standing back there?
Because there was no anomaly.
What are you doing?
Oh!
Oh my god.
I almost did it.
What are you doing?
There was no way.
no akasupa so she couldn't tell guys i know you guys i was
the akasupa but i did it for free the way you were standing
yeah i'm just like what haven't we gotten i'm just like what
is she doing no way there has to be an anomaly in here
there's no anomaly no guys we're waiting we're waiting for
the akasupa right now wait wait there's something on the
floor it's always been like It's salad fingers.
They got something new.
We're going past 4-5-13.
We went past it.
Yay!
New record.
Salad fingers.
God, first, first, Dr. Horrible.
What did you say about you?
You recognize these references.
You recognize the references, too.
There hasn't been anything with...
brother yeah i mean bread there was one where he grew taller
right oh no no he exploded just getting yeah he exploded
yeah why did the brother explode why did he explode not just
once but three times actually one in here i think so either
i don't see anything there's no faces on the floor and
someone gave me a blue super chat and was like akasupa wait
does that mean there's an anomaly or there's no anomaly does
blue mean safe Let's move Alright Alright here we go There
we go Swipe or no swiping Here we go Alright Let's wait This
is the right Yep yep There's no There's no anomalies And
then we wait Why are you having me press it You made up the
rule You are the one that made up the rule 515 What was the
Has there been one that we haven't done yet that we haven't
saw i think we haven't oh this one this one yeah it's the
blue screen this was the first one we got i think yeah it
was a long time ago yeah and then it like threw us off
because we saw it it was real okay okay 5 16 and i think we
haven't gotten the one with the lots of plugs right no we
did you're the one that called it out wasn't that on the
previous run though oh you're right we you're right oh
you're right yeah or did we i can't remember everything's
blending together you guys all these floors we went through
so many floors no oh no i don't know actually i don't know
brother we don't know brother brother brother we don't know
i think there's nothing here are you sure oh you're trusting
me are you sure no i meant i'm not trusting you you.
Brother.
That's your...
Guys, I don't know.
If we fuck up, we go back to zero.
All the way to zero.
Guys, you don't want to go back to zero, guys.
You don't...
Here we go.
Wait, why am I pressing it?
Because I pressed it last time.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Come on.
SCP.
SCP!
You.
What?
Chat.
What did we miss?
Why did we miss?
There was no anomalies.
Did we go to the wrong elevator?
No, no we didn't.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
This is the first level.
No.
What did we... Oh, wait.
Someone said review.
We can go review it.
What did we do?
Okay, now we have to review.
What did we miss?
No way.
What are you... There was no anomalies.
It wasn't the door.
We got that one.
It was like the first one we got.
Nobody super chatted us.
No smiley.
No one else noticed.
Nobody noticed.
Two, four, five.
Two, four, five, two, four, five.
two, four, five, two, two, four, there's...
Is it like a time thing, like with the head, you know?
Like we weren't looking in the right direction.
Someone said, what?
Under the shelf?
Is it this box?
The, that thing looks weird.
Oh my God.
What?
Look up.
Up?
Wait, wait, up.
Look up.
Look up?
Oh.
No.
Are you kidding me?
You see it.
Is it the 666?
Look up.
Look up at the box too.
It's this box right here.
Look.
They said look up.
There's 666 label.
My God.
Oh my God.
Here too.
Chat didn't know either.
Chat didn't know.
There was no super chat.
didn't know either you can't blame it on us we came here
there's like oh all the bottles say 6662 oh they used to say
ethanol and um i thought there would only be one 666 because
it's the trash can they they baited us they've always
they've always said one and now it's like several now it's
two this is messed up this is messed up this is messed up
it's not our fault guys It's never the streamers' fault.
One chat member got the labels right.
No, this is so messed up.
One guide in the correct direction.
The one guy was actually correct.
What is this?
Oh my god.
And on the final thing, on the final line!
That was so cheesy!
That was so, that was so cheap.
Oh my god, that was so cheap.
We were so happy getting to the sixth...
Bro, we're stuck at 500 forever.
Never got it.
We can speed run.
We know everything now.
We know them all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We knew everything.
Speed run, speed run, speed run.
Speed run, speed run.
Okay.
What is it?
666.
On the, on the, on the wrong elevator.
I saw you.
I saw you running over there.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We got this.
Okay.
We got, what 666 was it?
Was it on the trash can or the labels?
It was on the trash can.
Okay, okay, I'm keeping track so we can like, if we get all
the anomalies left, then we can just press.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Not us being like so excited for some of these.
We're gonna have to get the box one all over again too.
Oh no!
All right, I know how to do this faster.
How one person goes?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, here I go.
There I go.
I'm not a damn bitch.
It's going to force you in here once there's Johnny.
It's the bags.
It's a bag.
See?
Look at how fast it is.
So I can just press the button when you're...
What if I'm here?
What if it's a not...
What if it's nothing?
You have to go all the way back.
I'm going to lie to you at some point.
I'm going to tell you.
We all want to leave the hospital.
If you lie, it affects you too.
Here we go.
It's the boxes.
No, really?
I'm coming out.
I'm leaving.
I'm getting out of here.
The boxes?
I thought you were an expert on this.
What happened?
I'm coming out.
Yeah?
Any second now?
I'm coming out.
Do you see the boxes like getting pushed from the...
I'm just...
I'm coming out.
The box here disappears.
You see I'm kicking them one by one.
I'm coming out.
Oh, there you are.
Disappeared, didn't it?
You didn't do it yourself.
You did not do it yourself.
Oh my god.
There we go.
I'm on my way.
You got this go man.
Don't give too much of a baby.
I am not a baby.
I am trying to be efficient here I am not a baby.
I'm not a baby.
Uh, I think wait, hold on.
Let me check the labels.
Okay Check that smiley smiley smiley smiley smiley smiley
smiley smiley's on the light switch.
Yes.
All right.
Okay Oh my god.
We fucked up For 500 like four times already It was like
three.
It was like three.
Oh, now you can count.
I think this is our third run.
Now you can count.
Oh, no, actually, you don't.
This is our fourth run.
This is actually our fourth run.
It is for real?
No way.
I'm with you this time because I think it's no anomaly time.
I think you're right.
I'm double checking everything.
Okay, you're right.
And you're, see, I'm so good at gambling.
Okay.
probability wise i was right this game okay oh my god it's
so intense now it's so intense oh brother is exploding
brother is exploding close one all right exploding brother
we are missing the label six the label the baby the six
plugs and the the body heads wait in the face the labels The
baby.
The floor.
Oh, the face.
Face on the ground.
Salad fingers.
No label.
See, I'm helping now.
Yeah, because we're close.
Yeah, now we have to go all the way to the other one.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Go all the way down.
The hinges.
Yep, it's correct.
Okay.
We almost ruled.
Oh, yeah.
I'm used to checking it on the way to running there.
Yeah, from this side.
We need Johnny.
okay the floor we're good we're good we're good unless i
think it like slowly starts to appear though so we might
have to like wait a second which one the floor yeah like
it's the it's like the fade in like oh the qr code yeah yeah
i'm checking all um nothing on the floor the labels are
disinfectant um do we got the do we get the heads at the
trash can yet yeah we already got about that all right no
anomalies yeah we're good no anomalies check the door the
door is good we're good we're getting better it only took us
four tries but we're getting better now yes oh my god bing
bing bing yes okay oh baby baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby baby all right we
got baby out of the way we're still missing johnny floor
labels and trash bag labels we got trash bag okay wait what
was trash bag the trash oh the ones that yeah the trash bag
that moved yeah yeah yeah babytv it's johnny oh my god it's
johnny holy holy i wanted to look at me this time his eyes
kind of look to the right you're right
What's wrong with us anymore?
We need to get the floor 666, you guys.
For three hours.
We're close to four hours.
Oh, the door hinges.
We also got to worry about the door hinge.
666 labels.
All right, nice.
All right.
I think the door hinges are gonna be like the last one
There's nothing on the floor Wait, what are we missing?
We're missing the floor We're missing the Door hinge I think
nothing And also the one of all the six plugs Yeah, there's
nothing so I think we're good I think we're good Back to
there we're back to there we still have a whole other floor
we still have three more why did you suggest this i didn't
why did you agree to this 14 14 uh no it should be last
three right i think so last three so it's all anomalies no
this one uh unless it's the floor it's the it's a floor it's
all three so it's all how much you want to bet do you really
want to do this yeah yeah let's do it it's literally all
anomalies you know i'm right okay okay we'll do it you know
i'm right okay what are we missing we're missing the door
hinge and we're missing we can see from here yeah we can see
from here it's the six plugs how much you want to bet okay
it's the six plugs all right okay do it yeah do it all right
i'm gonna do it it's the six plugs all right The moment I
chose.
Do it.
And it's the door hinge.
I can see it again.
I told you.
Okay, that paused, though.
I literally held my breath.
I couldn't.
Please be right.
I told I'm so...
Oh, my God.
It's the back rooms.
I'm inside.
Is it me?
It's me.
I'm literally the sacro.
Sacrifice men you guys I'm trying to find it I don't know
what to do Oh my god Sacrifice myself Oh my god It's after
me!
It's after me!
Oh my god no wait
He has to break it!
He has to break it first!
What is this bullshit?
How do we lead him to that?
Let's see you can clutch this You can clutch this, you
clutch all How do I do it?
How do I do it?
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
I got it.
You're gaming.
Game of the year.
Why do I always survive?
Did he just sigh?
Did he just go, hmm?
This is it.
Oh, my God.
600, baby.
600.
We're almost there.
Brother.
Okay, it's the operation room.
Wow.
There's a lot.
going on in here oh my god okay and then there's an opera
there's another x-ray over here that we can't go in okay
there's x-rays there's uh there's a calendar here maybe june
we care about your health okay nice okay i think i think i
absorbed everything in okay there's a computer the screen is
off final stretch baby the final stretch let's just do it
we'll learn as we go
That's how we did it in four, five hundred, baby.
Why can't this one be in the middle of the room?
All right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Brother.
All the screens are off.
Nothing, no sixes anywhere.
I think it's no anomaly.
Oh my God, why am I glitching so bad?
I don't see any anomalies anywhere.
Oh, yeah, me too.
do oh whoa is that a glitch or is that is that an anomaly is
that anomaly i think oh oh i'm i'm glitching so much even
now yeah i think whoa whoa i think that's an anomaly is that
anomaly oh my god yeah that has to be anomaly there's no way
there's no way there's no well fine i mean we're in 601 yeah
it doesn't matter yeah yeah yeah that has to be an anomaly
it has to be That was cool.
That was a cool anomaly.
Yeah, I thought we were lagging.
I was like, whoa.
Oh, brother scares me every time, man.
That was such a creative anomaly, though.
Yeah, that one's fun.
Yeah.
Because you can't tell if it's Kuso Gay or...
Yeah, it's just the game itself.
May, June, July, we care about your health.
Disease history.
Nothing.
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything either.
Yeah.
I think we're actually good this time.
I'm not.
Oh my god.
You're on the wrong side?
No.
Don't fuck with us like that.
I'm checking now though.
I'm checking.
603.
And the labels.
Yeah.
We have to check the labels too.
Just in case.
Just to see if there's any sixes.
603.
Bing.
603, baby.
Let's go.
I think Brother's gonna be standing at one point.
Yeah, me too.
Or he's gonna change his face.
Okay, he's fine right now.
Hmm.
Nothing on the monitors.
Nothing on the side.
Nothing in the operating.
No 666 anywhere.
I'm checking.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
It's the same date.
History.
There's no way that there's nothing here.
I don't know.
We could have had two in a row.
No anomalies.
That's the secret one.
No anomalies for twice.
I don't think so.
Alright.
Wait, did they not hear that?
Hear what?
They're fucking with you.
There's no way.
What was that noise?
What do you mean?
I don't hear anything.
I'm being really.
Oh, that's you.
That's me.
Yeah.
They said hole on the bed?
What?
There's always been a hole here.
There's always been a hole there.
What hole?
This hole?
The opera.
Was that a girl?
What?
I'm scared now.
That's always been there.
Oh, this hole here, yeah.
It's always been there.
What do you mean?
Hold on.
Ah!
Wow.
Very realistic.
Look, we've been playing for almost four hours.
I can't dedicate a voice for it.
Okay, anyway.
Okay.
Up we go.
I'm aware of 603.
There's no way.
At best we retry three floors.
It's better than not true true true.
It's better than
Okay, let's see if there's a hole on the bed.
Let's see.
There was no hole on the bed There's no hole on the bed We
were like there's always been a hole we were thinking of
like the fucking chiropractor As like you massages and I
forgot this is an operating table No operating tables do
have holes in the bed Sometimes they have holes right Yeah
for brain surgery I don't know I don't know I thought it was
there to keep your head comfy Me too Okay well now we know
Whoa whoa what's the game the game Uh oh whoa it's us Oh
it's you it's following you It's my POV yeah it's your POV
And now we know, guys, at least it was like three floors.
Yeah, it's fine.
And then we called chat crazy.
We're like, guys, there's always been a hole on it.
You're crazy.
I'm the protagonist.
Yeah.
And they were like, literally, they were like, there's a
hole there.
We're like, oh, yeah.
Yeah, of course.
That is so confident.
No.
Of course there's a hole.
Oh my god.
All operating tables have a hole in it.
May, June, July.
History.
I don't think I see anything here.
Mystery.
Mm.
Is there.
There's no 666.
Brother.
We've been doing this for a while now, brother.
Yes, brother.
Brother.
Let us free.
okay but like also chad was gaslighting us while telling us
there's a hole yeah they were saying exactly so of course
we're gonna think that we think that everything is wrong
anything there's no sixes oh is there anything on the other
side we care about your health
Labels are normal.
The x-rays are normal, too.
Oh, there's no hole on the wall this time.
I thought I heard, like, a beeping, but it might have been,
like, just ominous.
Yeah, I think he's ominous.
I didn't hear a beeping.
Okay.
We go to the other side.
No clue.
All right.
No, it's not your fault, chat.
It's still this.
The whole, it, and the whole chat.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
It wasn't your chat that pointed it out.
Or anything, you know, and you chose to ignore.
I was gaslighting it.
Your chat said, all your, all that your chat said was, did
you hear the noise?
My chat actually called the hole in the bed.
They probably heard me like humming and were just like,
uh-oh.
We, that wasn't normal.
Obvious.
It wasn't, they were just trying to be helpful.
They were just trying to.
I don't, I, there's nothing.
I don't see anything.
I can't, uh, vitamin complex.
There's no six, six, six.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
I'm looking to see if any heads pop up.
Door hinges are good.
Wait, see if there's lag.
Oh, yeah.
No, no lag.
No lag.
So here, is it none?
The floor.
What about the floor?
Don't gaslight us.
Oh, my God.
The wires say six, six, six, six, six, six.
I saw it before you Because I trust my chat I saw it on my
chat I noticed that they were in perfect circles But I
thought he just copied and pasted them Thought it was being
a lazy dev After 600 floors This is the part where he gets
lazy Don't worry whips I know you guys saw it first Don't
worry dragons I knew you when you guys said 666 I knew you
guys were right Because I trust my chat.
Hole in the bed.
All right, we know hole in the bed is gone.
Yeah, hole in the bed is gone, everybody.
We got hole in the bed out of the way.
We're so fucking confident.
We were like schooling our chat.
We're like, there's always hole in the bed.
606.
Oh, my God, that's 10 away.
I mean, oh, my God.
Wait, what?
I was going to say 10 away.
from six six yeah i was gonna say like wait wait look
brother brother seemed polite oh my god brother brother
brother is talking to someone i think oh brother okay we're
going brother brother's been in this hospital a bit too long
brother finally is speaking all right up we go he looks like
he's laying right now like flirty i don't know whoever's
talking He was like, hey.
I know.
I like, I want that anomaly again if we fuck up.
I can't wait to get Flirty Brother back.
I miss Flirty Brother.
There's Raiden in the operating room.
What the fuck is that?
I don't know.
Why is he huge?
I triple dog dare you to go see him.
Yeah, go up to him.
We gotta do this again if we...
No, not necessarily.
He just, she's like half clipped to the floor.
What's she gonna do, phase through and kill me?
She might.
I'm leaving.
Oh, okay.
What happened to moral support?
I never said that.
Oh, now you're not gonna support me morally.
I'm never supported you morally.
Alright.
Right, and turn off the game console.
all right 608 we're getting there we're
missing the monitor in the lab there's a baby in the there's
a baby there's a baby there's a child baby you need out oh
wait what oh he's counting he's counting down he's counting
down he's 93 93 92 90 okay we have like a hundred seconds we
had like a hundred seconds how does it sound like that
though 95 94 93 somebody put baby in the corner yeah 609
baby hopefully there's no baby all right we got one baby
every floor has a baby no no nothing in the monitor oh oh
i'm lagging i'm lagging are you Oh, maybe I'm not.
I think it's because I bumped into you maybe.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm walking back and forth.
Okay, okay.
Never mind.
Um, we care about your health.
May, June, July.
Disease, history.
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything either.
Nothing on the labels.
All the labels are not 666.
I think we're fine.
Yay, we're at the closer door!
We're at the closer x-ray!
I'm trusting you, I'm trusting you.
Okay, then you go back into the room then.
Then you go back into the room.
I'm scared.
You're gonna trust me and you're not confident enough.
I'm scared, I don't know, I'm nervous.
usually the things are i don't know okay i people are like
blood but like they're not even confident about it they're
saying like is that blood by the brother but i don't see
anything at all blood by the brother i don't think so i
think they're they're being way too specific yeah there's
blood what what are you talking about where where behind the
brother there's no blood anywhere blood by the are we really
on the cabinet door what what okay i'm sure pretty sure i'm
so confused i am i am confused too huh i'm trying to see i'm
trying to look around to see if we miss anything blood
inside you that's a medic guy i'm dead all right that's
ectoplasm get it right all right oh my god okay i mean we
get this right at 6 10.
okay we just just rip off the band-aid man just rip off the
band-aid come on oh my god oh thank god oh thank god oh
thank you ah what just happened oh oh um hello where are you
where are you i'm in exit eight you're in exit eight you got
yes i'm in exit eight you're got teleported i want to get
teleported i'm in exit eight too
no way keep left oh shoot wait are we supposed to go
backward if it's oh yeah yeah yeah we go back we go back
because it's anomaly yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there it is there it is Yeah, yeah, yeah, there it is.
It's actually Exit 8.
We got Isakai to Exit 8.
Oh, we're back.
Wait, you were back?
Okay, I think that's an anomaly, guys.
I don't know about that one.
Is it the same dev?
No, it's a different dev.
It's a parody.
That's so funny.
We got Isakai to Exit 8.
Some of these, some of these, like, anomalies are pretty
good.
Yeah, they're actually pretty funny.
oh wait I think I'm lagging I think this is lag yeah yeah
wait is it uh unless we just pushed each other weird okay
I'm going inside oh wait I'm lagging yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's oh I'm trying to get out let me out let me out
let me out let me out I see it pushes you back oh my gosh oh
I still can't believe I teleported to exit in I know That
was crazy.
That was a good one.
You didn't even want to join me.
I went in.
Okay.
Is there any 666?
I'm now paranoid for any 666 references.
I know, right?
I'm not.
Ever since room 515.
I'll never forget 515.
I'll never forgive.
Never forget.
516.
I'll never forget 516.
This one looks good, I think.
Yeah, I think so, too.
anything behind the brother any blood where's the blood
alright I think we're good it's fine yeah yeah alright
heading to the other side no we have to head to the other
side doki check the labels right you check the labels sure
time to look at the numbers time to look at the numbers time
to look at the
this is your fault this is your fault this is your fault
this is your fault you said you checked we're reviewing
we're reviewing we're reviewing we're reviewing oh my god
we're not getting stuck we're not getting stuck here what
was it what was it labels no they're fine Were they supposed
to be closer together?
The calendar?
We care about your health.
I think that's what it says.
Is the X-ray supposed to be closer together?
Look up.
There's nothing up top.
What was it?
Wait, actually.
The plugs?
Wait, what do you mean the plugs?
Oh my god.
Oh.
It's the walls.
Oh my god.
I just saw them.
That is so cheeky!
Oh my god.
It doesn't appear until...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, they're making it really obvious.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I can't believe we didn't see that.
Oh my god.
We're at six.
It's because they don't appear soon enough.
Oh, they don't appear soon enough.
Oh no.
Alright, go to the other one.
Speedrunner's Bane.
Zero.
This is zero.
Just keep going.
Give it up for the four hours.
We're gonna make it God you're actually you're actually
right.
It's only four hours of this game Give it up for our number
four
Okay, we got majority anomalies this time so yeah, it's
true.
It's true.
Well, we get to see we get to see flirty Flirty guy again I
miss 30 brother But it's the same Maybe it's the walls It's
the wall Wait is it the walls Are you sure?
Yeah Oh you're right Yeah it is Yeah it's the walls Oh good
good good We got it out of the way I got it out of the way I
was like Are my eyes deceiving me Because I Because we went
through that
Oh my god In another world It would have been like Five
floors left In another world Why couldn't they be The first
one last time too, right?
Anomaly, anomaly, come over here.
I'm speed running.
I see it.
I saw it.
Then monitor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, we get to do Exit 8 again!
Oh, yeah!
That one's fun.
Yeah.
I wonder if it would be the same one.
The same anomaly with the poster.
Oh, maybe.
Probably, right?
Yeah, probably.
Unless they coded, like, several.
The one I don't want, I don't like the lagging one.
It hurts my brain.
Oh, the lagging one was freaky.
There's no anomalies that we haven't got yeah there's a few
so like i'm worried but i think this one's okay yeah i don't
think yeah i think this one's okay yeah we're good yeah to
the next floor to the next
floor i won uh discord lag
all right here we go i didn't realize this was like
competition You held your note for a long time.
I assumed that we were trying to compete here.
No, I mean, that's what you would assume, isn't it?
You know, no 666 on the floor.
No baby.
No baby and nothing seems odd.
No hole in the...
In the thing.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
I think we're good.
Yeah, we're good.
Are we?
Yeah.
Ceiling?
What's wrong with the ceiling?
They always say ceiling.
really do they never stop with the ceiling all right here we
go okay here we go we're so close almost less than more than
10 left 11 left go go go go go go brother that's nothing no
cables everything's fine no sixes of care about your house
labels are fine may june july no history hmm ceiling nothing
it says exit here i think we're good there's no hole in the
wall let's go really two in a row two in a row the game's
being nice to us let's go okay okay okay all right i'm
worried about the one thing that's like we because we
haven't seen three anomalies yeah i know it's like we don't
know what to express what could the three what could the
three
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, I think so, how did
we not, I thought we already did the brother, I'm not the
brother, the monitor, yeah, I thought we already did the
monitor, or any, let's see your smoker baby, I think the
next one will be the baby, Baby in the corner.
Baby in the corner.
Alright.
Oh, a predator is too.
Nice.
Okay.
Because I was like, I don't remember seeing two.
Oh, no baby in the corner.
It's a cable.
Oh, 666.
666.
Why can't it be the closer elevator?
God damn it.
Give us the closer one.
Wow, someone's so slow today.
No, I have a bug that's flying in my face.
Oh, no.
bug know about 666 i killed it oh whoa with your hand i
thought you're a ghost i killed it just now is it a ghost
bug it is now nothing here oh it's a lady it's riding riding
riding go go go go go go turn off the game console oh my god
oh my god we're doing it we're doing it we're speed running
We're so good now Woo It's okay Oh Nine Seven more Oh my god
Punching you so we can get there faster Zesty brothers Zesty
brothers Zesty brother Nope No Baby Nope Hole in the bed
Hole in the bed Hole in the bed Disgust We need to punch
each other You know We need to get the 6-6-6 We need to get
the 6-6-6 We were like, okay, we found it, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go.
All right.
Come on.
There we go.
I wonder if you failed the exit 8, do I lose?
I don't know.
Like before, right?
Yeah, yeah, because we got it right before.
We still have the lag.
No, baby.
Wait, the camera.
What the fuck?
Look at it.
Oh, I saw it.
I saw it.
Oh, what?
Oh, my God.
That's so weird.
That's like the camera, the dead POV.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
well that's kind of fun yes that's fun all right someone
needs to needs to work out more there i was looking at it i
was looking at it do not want to leave the hospital i'm
enjoying my time it's literally a camera all right zesty
brother zesty brother zesty brother zesty brother zesty
brother baby in the corner baby in the corner baby in the
corner baby in the corner baby in the corner baby in the
corner we just have brother and exudate and that's all the
ones we've seen right yeah are you I was like where did you
go 92 92 99 what happens when he counts to zero and that's
what I'm wondering I'm really kidding.
I swear to God, man.
We have to go back to the six of you.
Will it be worth it?
You want me in the elevator?
Don't you?
Go on.
Go closer to our room.
Go closer.
What do you say?
He's not clowning anymore.
I don't think he expects us to stay here.
I don't think he does.
I'm not lazy.
I tell you, lazy Deb, lazy Deb.
He doesn't even fucking count all the way to the end.
If you don't get count all the way to the end, start from
10.
I know, right?
The dev got tired.
It was like, well, you're supposed to be gone.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, exit.
Okay, I'm going to see if you...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What?
I want to see you pop into existence.
oh okay okay i can yeah yeah yeah oh my god it's an anomaly
is it the same one yeah it's the same oh okay let's see how
what you look like when you pop back in here i go where are
you i'm coming back oh i'm here it's this way
Up we go.
Where are we missing?
I think...
Oh, we're missing Zesty Brother.
Oh, I think two others, right?
Yeah, two others we haven't seen before.
I don't think we got the Lag one.
Okay, so then what is...
We have one anomaly that we haven't got before.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
We got this.
Nope.
Oh, whoa, oh.
Is it Lag?
No, no, no.
Look, look, look.
It's like unfinished textures.
No textures.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, everything has no textures.
Oh, my God.
Oh, so everything's...
Everything has to be anomni now.
Everything is a PNG.
No, no.
Okay, 14.
Oh, wait, no.
We're missing one.
No, I think it's better to...
Yeah.
We're missing one because we have...
We're missing...
We have done two, so...
Yeah, yeah, we have to check.
Okay, it's fine.
Lazy give.
All right, here we go.
My immersion.
This isn't a video game.
This is real life.
I'm stuck in the game.
We're stuck in a hospital.
It's the brother!
Zesty brother!
He's having a good time.
Okay, nice.
Lag and then unknown.
All right, off we go.
Not, we didn't take the wrong elevator, too.
We did it.
We didn't take the wrong elevator.
We're good.
We got this, we got this, we got this, we got this.
How, how we can't fuck it up now?
It's gotta be the lag, right?
Yeah, it has to be the lag.
Or something else.
Or no anomaly.
Run around to see if we lag at all?
No lag.
Oh, wait.
I don't like this because we don't...
We don't know.
Oh, I don't like this because it's not lag.
It's too much of a mystery.
This is a mystery.
Any sixes?
The labels are fine.
I'm looking at the calendar.
Medical center first.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
There's no 666.
Oh, no.
Nothing with the table, the bed.
History, disease, history.
There's no sixes.
Nothing with the x-rays.
They all look the same the walls aren't smiling this time no
I don't like this minute.
I don't know either.
I don't like this.
Yeah, we got the wall the wall was the first one We got
yeah, the X-rays are okay.
There's no six six six Oh
Okay, okay, I'll press the button.
I'll take oh, okay No, we press it.
Wait what?
It's alive!
We don't have to do this!
Oh, yeah, I separate the lies.
I lied, I lied, I lied, I'm lagging in the elevator.
It's like, it's definitely...
This is it!
Good luck, Mint.
Oh, oh.
We're at the...
What floor are we at?
Six, six, six!
We're here.
Here we go.
Just run for it.
There's no...
Wait, the elevator's not open, though.
yeah oh oh oh oh i think something is gonna come from that
no but then like oh oh maybe you're right i think we need to
turn around oh maybe you're right i think we need to turn
around i think we're right i think we're right oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa yeah that was a png i think we just got a oh
there's a wheelchair she goes the she goes it's your cousin
it's your cousin it's my cousin that's right it's just a
body bag it's a body bag it's just a normal guy It's Anita!
It's the normal guy!
Oh my god!
It's the- How did you die?
How did you die?
I don't know!
I think we have to like, as soon as it starts ringing, we
gotta, we gotta turn around.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, that means he's faster than us.
Let's mess up!
Okay, okay.
There we go.
Yeah, turn around, turn around, turn around.
We wasted too much time.
We looked at her for too long.
Let's go, just stop!
Don't look back!
Don't look back.
You're- you're- you're- I'll punch you!
Do victory!
I'll punch you!
I'll punch you if you get too close!
Okay, okay, punch me!
Punch me!
I'll punch you if you get too close!
Normal guy, normal guy!
You're doing normal things!
Oh my god.
Are you punching me?
I'm punching, yes I am!
You're not working!
I'm punching you!
I'm doing my best!
Oh, it worked, it worked, it worked, it worked.
Don't die!
Don't die, don't die!
I'm gonna do it!
I'm surface my life!
I did everything I call it!
I'm touching Oh my god, it's a doctor Oh my god, he was
right there He was right there Holy shit, it was right
behind us We did it Complete normal mode Oh my god, it was a
doctor He wanted to get paid I like how this entire critic
This is one guy Marketing manager Sales manager Developers
anomaly acting school six six six oh i know what we're
playing next oh my god wait are we going to classroom six
how are you gonna do is it gonna be floors wasn't there an
easy mode to this like yeah the easy mode is that there's a
routine so like ever like uh wait what wait we're still here
i thought this was i got an achievement too that was just
like you escaped the hospital but have Yeah, but like is
like But like what is the hard what what's the difference?
I don't know What's the difference mint?
I don't know.
Just keep going.
Just go to the next go to the elevator I thought it was
over.
It's fine.
Just keep going.
I thought it but it's back to zero No, it's back to zero.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
It's all good.
Oh, no I don't understand.
What would be different?
I think the game is over.
I think the game is over, too.
I think there's a return to menu button that we are allowed
to play.
Yeah, I see it, too.
I see it.
You see that menu?
Oh, my God.
It just showed up.
I got into the elevator and the return to menu button showed
up.
Did you see it?
Oh, my God, me too.
Yeah, it just happened.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I'm in the menu.
Oh, you late.
No, it like showed up She's gone, you guys She's gone I'm
going to the next floor You're going to that next floor Are
you actually?
There's like a giant handprint What are these?
What are you doing?
Is that you?
That's me That's the anomaly How did you do that?
Wait, how did you do that?
You were over there Orange They're both orange late Which is
the OG?
That one's only one that's orange.
That one's orange for me.
They're both orange.
I think I fucked up the light.
I think you messed it up.
Everything is like light now.
It's so bright.
This has to be the hard mode, right?
So let's go to the menu.
I'm going to go to the menu and see if it's on the hard
mode.
It has to be the hard mode.
Okay, I'm returning.
But like, what's the hard mode, though?
Let's see.
New game.
Oh, yeah, it's hell.
Return to floor 0, 0, 0 if you fail.
Oh, it's the same.
It's just that you...
Go back to zero, okay, so we finished, we beat the game!
Wait, is this actually, but is it?
It basically, like, instead of returning back to, like, you
know, instead of returning back to, like, 400, 400, 400,
300, it goes back to zero.
Yeah, but is it also different floors?
I don't think so.
I'm starting a new game.
Are you fucking?
I'm curious.
Go some balls.
Well, you have to host a game.
You have to host it.
No, it's bloody.
It's bloody.
So, yeah.
The hard mode is the bloody mode.
I assume it is.
We did it.
We beat the game.
It only took us four hours.
What's the speedrun of this?
Speedrun.com.
It took us less than four hours.
You're right.
Because we had one hour.
setup times yeah one hour to set up time and also it's not
been four hours it's been not yet it's been one week wait oh
my god we can be in the we can get in there's only we should
submit our runs to speedrun.com there's only two
participants yo we're gonna be at the leaderboards first
place is the creator.
Stop.
I think that's cheating.
That is actual cheating.
I like how in first place is the creator of the time.
What's his time?
30 minutes?
34 minutes?
That's not fair.
Not even fair.
Oh wait, no, it's not the creator.
It's some other guy.
I messed up.
It's not the creator.
I thought it was the creator because I saw Hong Kong.
Because I know that Dev is from Hong Kong.
But maybe with it, a friend and he like oh yeah you're right
it was one month we could be the third and fourth place if i
submit first i get third place oh my god dokey the creator
of that background just followed me on twitter wait i'm
gonna like the laundry mat go get the laundry mat you have
to use the laundry
to when will we get how did they know how did they know when
will we when will we get meaning that ghost girl at the
laundromat roleplay asmr i will get the laundry mat i'll get
the laundry mat background everybody when will we get
laundromat asmrp man when i'm a maid i belong in the laundry
Oh, I'm tired This was fun This was fun though And it was a
team effort With the Wisp and the Dragoons Working together
The Wisp goons Team effort Team effort We all did this
together guys Good job everybody Good job Dragoons Give
yourself a pat on the back Oh especially the Wisp's helped
like crazy crazy Yeah Yeah even though like didn't believe
you sometimes dragoons like the hole in the bed oh yeah you
know but i know doki like kind of doubts you guys all the
time but it's okay no wait i always believed i always did
you see you agree i don't know good job everybody good job
every wish good job every dragoons you guys did it remember
the timestamp whoever gets the most correct guys okay
whoever gets the most correct then what is it what do we get
what do we have to do we have to what's the punishment like
i don't know okay we decide the punishment later with that
oh yeah you decide you want to decide only if you only if
you know are you not confident are you not confident that
you're gonna win you want to agree i'm pretty confident i'm
pretty confident you're pretty confident yeah decide
something right now then you're so confident You're the one
who was just like, well, decide later.
Yeah, because we don't know.
We don't know the result.
If you're so confident in figuring out something now.
Loser has to use the other person's gamer subs code.
Okay, deal.
Deal.
Let me grab, let me buy the free pack.
The free sample pack.
Oh, no.
Oh, TGs, guys.
TGs, everybody.
Are you going to chat with your wisp?
Because I'm just going to head off.
We did a long stream.
I'll chat just a little bit, but yeah, not very much.
TGs, man.
TGs and cookies.
Bye.
We did it.
We survived.
Bye-bye.
All right.
I'm really tired now.
I didn't think we would play for hours.
that's so fun that's really really really fun i hope you
guys enjoyed it a lot i am going to head out now because i'm
really tired and actually have a lot of stuff i still i'm
doing last minute last minute skin suit stuff so i hope you
guys had a great time everybody uh that was a very fun game
and i just want to say as always everybody say hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you step for me head to ben because you
deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.